the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne who moves
the house adjourned from the session of
march 10 20 22. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it in
the house is adjourned
house will attend to a prayer by house
chaplain reverend bob stewart pastor of
saint paul's united methodist church in
manchester
good morning
so this morning i thought i would begin
offering the prayer of saint francis of
assisi his prayer for peace
i've adjusted some of the words i took
me
and put us
and took i and put we
in its place let's be in a spirit of
prayer
lord
make us an instrument of your peace
where there is hatred let us sow love
where there is injury
pardon
where there is doubt
faith
where there is despair
hope
where there is darkness light
where there is sadness joy
o divine master grant that we may not so
much seek to be consoled
as to console
to be understood
as to understand
to be loved
as to love
for it is in giving that we receive
it is in pardoning
that we are pardoned
and it is in dying that we are born to
eternal life
a loving god we pray
for the people of ukraine
we pray for the people of russia
we pray for the world you have created
we pray for the united states of america
we pray for our great state of new
hampshire and all the representatives
that are here today
please prepare us for the day that
stretches out before us
you know exactly what this day will
contain
whereas we only have vague ideas about
it
sometimes we wish we could see a road
map
that would show all the twists and turns
of today's journey
we would feel better prepared if we
could somehow visualize what is on the
road ahead
even though we don't know what is
waiting on the path ahead
we trust that you have equipped each of
us here today
to work together in harmony and peace
that we work together for the good
people of this great state
and always strive to keep them in our
minds as we enter into making decisions
on their behalf
be with us o god and give us the wisdom
and strength to serve our constituents
with integrity
to you o god of love we lead and serve
to your glory let there be peace on
earth
and let it begin with us
amen
the chair recognizes a member from
hollis representative susan waller will
lead us in the pledge of allegiance
the chair recognizes the hollis
brookline high school honors choir under
the direction of matt barbarossa who
will now perform our national anthem
[Music]
what so proudly we
each
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
again
house will attend to request for leaves
of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives birch credian cleaver
ellis mary griffin harvey popper
lundgren salloway snow tudor barney the
day important business representatives
ayer vortis bunky cody cross de palma
font no
horgan hunt mayville macbeth mcbride
mckinney stavis trottier the day illness
in the family representatives eliot and
newton
these leaves of absences will be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
house will attend to the introduction of
guests
mr speaker please welcome allison
sullivan guest of representative mooney
faye linda default guest of
representative pearl
robert and taylor huff father and
daughter of representative huff
brigadier general don baldock u.s army
retired guest of representative healy
chaz rogers guest of representative
homola fourth grade students from broken
ground school in concord guests of
representative bartlett they are with us
in the gallery today
[Applause]
welcome to the new hampshire house
the house will attend to the consent
calendar mr speaker from the committee
on criminal justice and public safety
house bill 1349 removed by
representative lawton
from the committee on education house
bill 1646 removed by representative de
shays
from the committee on election law house
bill 1064 removed by representative
allegro
from the committee on election law house
bill 1473 removed by representative
homila
from the committee on legislative
administration cacr 24 removed by
representative silber
from the committee on legislative
administration cacr 25 removed by
representative le branch
from the committee on legislative
administration cacr 26 removed by
representative lawton
from the committee on legislative
administration cacr 27 removed by
representative silber
from the committee on municipal and
county government house bill 1155
removed by representative terozian
there any other bills to be removed
senator osborne moves consent calendar
with the relevant amendments printed in
today's health record be adopted are
rated for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes having to
consent calendar is adopted
representative horgan declared a
conflict of interest on house bill 1592
fn and did not participate in the vote
for the consent calendar
the house will now
for what reason to memorize uh question
of the chair
state your question uh mr speaker can
you confirm
for the members that your office has
reviewed the amendments on the bills for
the calendar this week and inform us
whether or not any of them have been
found as non-germane
we have revealed any amendments that
were brought to our attention
thank you
house and i'll attend the bills on the
regular calendar
majority of the committee on children
family law to which was referred house
bill 1280 an act prohibiting a parent's
refusal to vaccinate a child pursuant to
an order of the state or federal
government to be used as a basis for
terminating parental rights having
considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative joshua caller for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the result following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to register
legislate representative patrick long
for the minority of the committee
the amendment is
one two 09128
and it is in your seat pockets
are you ready for the question on the
amendment
okay
the bill's on second reading and opened
a
further amendment
representative keller you'll recognize
and introduce your amendment
thank you thank you mr speaker
i rise to
move floor amendment 2022-0912-h
this
language was
discussed in the committee and
was
just not available at the time of
of the vote and
i believe that it addresses some of the
concerns of the
minority report and doesn't change the
intent of the bill and so i hope that
you will support it thank you very much
the question is on the floor amendment
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
the eyes have it the floor amendment is
adopted
chair recognizes
the emotion before us now was out to
pass as amended the chair recognizes
representative long
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the ought to pass
uh has amended a
question
uh this is the first i see of the floor
amendment sold i
just read it before i got up here i
agree the termination of parental rights
are not be based solely on parents
agreeing to vaccinate the child using
current exemptions the concern is when
which parent should the decision rely on
when the parents disagree
especially in divorce parenting where
conflicts exist and at all times those
conflicts have a detrimental effect on a
child
the bill doesn't state that anymore
so the the
the issue with with
the issue with
which parent has that
effect is for an example uh
signing up your child for football when
one parent believes that it's it's
detrimental to the child's health
one child believes that the game would
improve the overall mental health and
confidence of the child at which at
which parent
would these decisions go to
now
i know in children of family law
committee has always looked at bills
that would not create conflict
and for that reason i asked the house to
oppose the motion of ought to pass thank
you mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative
ocala
thank you mr speaker
so the
um i have to disagree uh with the
minority that this will create conflict
the only conflict that this is talking
about is between the parents and the
state
that this
that vaccination status shall not be
used by the state as a reason to
terminate
parental rights and
um
you know there's valid reasons medical
religious
reasons why
someone may choose to not or change the
schedule of vaccinations and so those
parents should
not lose the
custody of their kids because of those
tough decisions so i hope you support
this
as amended thank you very much
does the member yield the questions
thanks
no no thanks
the member does not yield
the question before us is
the majority report about to pass as
amended on house bill 12
80.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on children
and family law to which was referred
house bill 1286 and act relative to the
modification of parental rights and
responsibilities having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate
senator joshua keller for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representation of
deborah altschule or for the minority of
the committee the chair recognizes
representative altrueller for
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
house bill 1286 is a language change
to rsa
461a11 which is part of our chapter on
parental rights and responsibilities
which says the court may issue an order
modifying a permanent order concerning
parental rights and responsibilities
under
any of the following circumstances
and then the law goes on to outline a
nine part list of those circumstances
the change proposed here
would make the word make the beginning
of that title read the court may issue
an order modifying a permanent order
concerning parental rights and
responsibilities
only under the following circumstances
and then again refer to that exhaustive
list
of nine circumstances
we would think that um
this would be such a minor change that
shouldn't this have been sorted out
earlier in the courts
and yet the courts have asked us to do
exactly this because lower courts have
found ways to rule outside the scope of
that list the court may issue an order
modifying a permanent order concerning
parental rights and responsibilities
under the following circumstances and
i'll summarize them as this that both
parents agree to that modification
that the court finds
repeated intentional and unwarranted
interference
by one parent with the residential
responsibilities of the other parent
the court may then intervene without
necessarily showing harm to the child
because the court determines
that such a change would be in the best
interest of the child third the court
finds by clear and convincing evidence
the high standard that the child's
present environment is detrimental to
that child's physical mental or
emotional health
if the parties have substantially equal
periods of residential responsibility
for that child and either asserts that
the court finds the original allocation
of parental rights and response
responsibilities is not working
if the court finds by clear and
convincing evidence that a minor child
is of sufficient maturity to make a
sound judgment that the court
may give substantial weight to their
preference
if the modification
makes either a minimal change or no
change at all in the allocation of
parenting time between the parents the
court could determine that that will be
in the best interest of the child
and there are five more which i will not
go on with today but it is an exhaustive
list
when it was written in 2005
and then subsequently modified five
additional times by the legislature the
intention was to list
every possible issue that would arise to
necessitate changing a previously
permanent
parent
parenting order
and yet
petitions to change permanent parenting
orders that are outside the scope of
this very comprehensive list continue
two lower court decisions modifying
parenting pans out parenting plans
outside the scope of that list
provided in rsa461a11
were then overturned by the new
hampshire supreme court
once in 2019 december fourth of two of
2009 i'm sorry
that which is the much more case and in
2007 the larue case
in larue
the most recent of these overturns by
the supreme court
the court observed that the legislature
intended
contract principles to apply in
determining whether the parties have
agreed to a modification pursuant to the
statute
indicating that the first steps to a
limitation in the court's power to alter
a parenting plan the ability will or
resources needed to appeal a lower court
decision to the supreme court is
available to all citizens
and the court has made clear on at least
two occasions that a legislative fix to
the language of rsa
6461a
is needed
to better serve the best interests of
children and her and their parents we
believe that rsa
that the rsa that currently reads the
court may issue and or and order
modifying a permanent order concerning
parental rights and responsibilities
under any of the following circumstances
be changed to reflect the direction
given to us by the courts
and change it to
only under the following circumstances
colleagues
the vote in committee was eight to seven
we ask you to please push the red button
and vote no so another motion can be
made thank you
chair recognizes representative vicala
thank you mr speaker
this
this language went to the supreme court
and they interpreted that the list is
exhaustive
so this change is not necessary that is
the current state of the law in new
hampshire and so this bill is just
paperwork trying to clarify something
that the state has already clarified
it's not going to change policy in the
state of new hampshire and so it's just
busy work
for the legislature and so i
urge you to vote itl thank you very much
the motion before us is to
the majority report of
in expedient to legislate on house bill
are you ready for the question
division has been requested members will
take your seats
and make sure you've turned on your
voting stations
so
this will be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative long
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that adding
simplifying the statute by adding the
only word would make it clearer for
litigants
then would i press the red button
thank you
chair recognizes representative de
simone for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that the proposed change this
bill asks for is already correctly
interpreted by the supreme court
therefore totally unnecessary
then i will be pressing the green button
to support the majority report of itl
thank you mr speaker
two wonderful parliamentary inquiries
the question before us is the majority
report of inexpediting to legislate on
house bill 1286
this will be a division vote you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
you're in the voting mode
hey
representative cat's chorus
you got to give me a thumbs up or a
thumbs down
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
176 voting yay 155 voting aid at
committee reports adopted
before i get into this bill if if
everybody would give me their attention
for a minute
um if if you know you're going to have a
request a division or a roll call
i request that you please let us know so
that we can go into the same system as
we did last thursday where i'll announce
the last speaker
and then we'll pretty much go right into
the vote to save as much time as
possible
last last thursday we it went very well
and i think if we do the same thing this
week will be the same way
and
just so
everybody knows
i apologize for sitting down but
i took a pretty good fall on the ice on
sunday myself so i'm
not in that good of shape either so um
i'll probably be sitting down a good
part of this session
the majority of the committee on
children and family law to which was
referred house bill 1305
an act relative to the temporary to
temporary alimony having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass president of josh o'calla for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same would be
another degree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative cassandra levesque for
the minority of the committee the chair
recognizes representative levesque to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
temporary alimony is meant to be just
that temporary
it is meant to be put into place while
the divorce is being processed it is not
meant to be a long-term solution
temporary alimony is available to
spouses who need financial assistance
during the divorce process in order to
cover living expenses and is separate
from temporary child support payments
when alimony is decided it takes time
for the court to consider and calculate
all assets to determine if alimony will
be part of the
divorce decree
the courts must also consider if the
requesting spouse lacks sufficient
income property or both to be
financially independent considering the
spouse's marital lifestyle
they also have to consider if the
recipient is unable to be
self-supporting through employment at a
standard that meets reasonable needs or
is
a custodial parent
sorry about that
custodial parent to a child who needs
make it impossible for the parent to
work outside the home once the court
determines that support is needed it
will then decide the duration and amount
of alimony depending on the length of
the marriage and several other factors
this bill will make these steps more
difficult and not give the parties an
equal opportunity to calculate their
assets the courts need time when making
these calculations and this bill takes
away that needed time thank you mr
speaker and i will not yield to any
questions
chair i recognize the representative
keller speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
so currently
uh for temporary alimony there is no
requirement that they follow the normal
cal alimony calculations
and that
that temporary alimony doesn't go
towards the time
you're allowed to be paying alimony and
so all this does is
say why are we why are we using a
different calculation than we normally
would and why aren't we counting the
money that you pay as part of the time
that you have to pay
and there is an exception if there is
shown irreparable harm from following
this process
um
in the legislation so i hope that you
will uh vote
ought to pass thank you very much
the question before us is the majority
report about to pass on house bill 1305
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it committee report is
adopted
majority committee on children and
family law to which was referred house
bill 1382 when act relative to the
presumption of shared parenting and
determination of parental rights and
responsibilities having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment and recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
president of josh o'calla for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having to
consider the same and be an annual
degree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate president of
deborah altschuler for the minority of
the committee
the amendment is zero eight eight seven
h printed in house record 10
a pages 55.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the i's have it an amendment is adopted
the chair recognizes representative all
troller four to speak against the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
this bill as amended
adds a new definition
to the first part of chapter 461a
parental rights and responsibilities it
states that the definition
of shared parenting
will be redefined as quote an
arrangement in which each parent plays a
substantially equal role in dis
decision-making responsibility
and
or more of the child's residential time
is spent with each parent
a presumption of shared parenting in the
determination of parental rights and
responsibilities
is not in the best interest of children
as it would force a parenting schedule
beginning
at
127.75 days per year
making that a legal presumption
current statute already clearly outlines
how
the courts should determine residential
responsibility and parenting in new
hampshire
these statutes are designed to make
decisions that are in the best interest
of the child
current parental rights and
responsibilities law
provide for a range of considerations to
to determine what is in the children's
best interest
the law presumes that children do best
when children have frequent and
continuing contact with both parents
it provides for consideration to make
parenting schedules that best protect
the child's safety and allows for the
consideration of the impact domestic
abuse has or has had on the child
current law
also ensures parenting schedules
consider the safety of an abused parent
this is a good policy
it is a good policy and should stay in
place
house bill 1382 as amended
writes out
the best interest of the child or the
children
we know and we have written into our
laws in
rsa461a part two that children do best
when both parents have a stable and
meaningful involvement in their lives
and when parents get along with each
other and are in positions to make
determination on their own without core
intervention it's better for children
it's better for everybody but that's not
the reality for many new hampshire
children and families in fact
the protections in place in rsa461a
are designed to protect children
in those highly volatile families where
domestic violence is present
the committee received testimony from
new hampshire legal association's dove
project that is the domestic violence
advocacy project that on average
it takes a domestic abuse victim
seven times
before they are able to leave an abusive
relationship for good
one contributing factor
is fear of losing custody of the
children
house bill 1382 lends credibility to an
abuser's control tactics by supporting
the idea
that if you leave
you aren't getting those kids
if the jumping off point is
automatically
a 50 50 custody of the children what
incentive is there for a victim to leave
from a victim's perspective
isn't it better to stay in the abusive
relationship to be there to protect the
children
rather than leave the children
unprotected in the abuser's care because
the court has a presumption of shared
parenting time
this bill forces an impossible choice on
victims
it contemplates the rights of one parent
over the safety of another
hb 1382 considers parental rights before
determining what is best or safest for
the child or children
this bill places the burden on a victim
tipping the balance in favor of an
abusive parent it lacks proper
consideration for the safety of the
child
it lacks proper consideration for the
safety of the abused parent
safety of abused parents and children
the minority of this committee believes
the current statute that uses the best
interests of the child
as a presumption
is effective and that hbill hb 1382
jeopardizes that
legislation that prioritizes equal
parenting time as its baseline
edges out other critical safety factors
and prioritizes parental wishes
over the best interest of the child
to make shared parenting presumptive
upholds in an abusive environment
as the norm
supporters of this bill have said that
domestic abuse or criminal assault are
rebuttable factors
however
the standard of this bill though
establishes a blanket presumption of one
size fits all
until it doesn't
and
until it doesn't doesn't could be lethal
we know this
that is not a child-centered policy
the minority of this committee believes
the new hampshire current statute that
uses the best interest of the child
as a presumption
is effective
and house bill 1382
jeopardizes that
respectfully
we ask that you please press the red
button
so another motion can be made
this is going to be a division vote
so members take your seats we're down to
the last speaker
chair recognizes representative keller
speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i agree with a lot of the sentiments
expressed by the other speaker
that
children do best when they have both
parents having an active role in their
children's lives unless
that role is deemed to be
hazardous and in the amended language
there is a
uh
place
in that language that the that the judge
decides whether or not it is appropriate
for the child to have
continued relationships with both
parents and if they
are if those kids are
better served by having continued
relationships with both parents then
it is the majority
of the committee's opinion that that be
a substantial amount of
of
opportunity to
to be parented by both parents and so i
hope that you will vote this
otpa thank you very much
the question before us is the
majority report about to pass as amended
on house bill 1382
this is going to be a division vote
the chair recognizes
chair recognizes representative
alterwell for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
if i know that the current parents
rights and responsibilities chapter
461-a
centers its policy on the belief that
children do best when both parents have
a stable and meaningful involvement in
their lives
and if i know that defining shared
parenting as an automatic default to a
specific percentage of residential time
without actually defining residential
time is a gap in this bill
and if i know that many parents who need
court involvement in their custody and
parenting plan have high conflict
relationships where domestic abuse is
present and is a danger to children's
safety
then would i now press the red button so
another motion can be
made recognizes representative nelson
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that shared
parenting offers families the benefits
of both parents building relationships
with their kids
encouraging healthy child development
and creating a platform for parents to
collaborate efforts for their children's
well-being and if i believe that this
bill as amended presumes shared custody
where a relationship with both parents
is found by the court to be in the best
interest of the child
and if i believe that this bill as
amended addresses the concerns expressed
in the minority report would i now press
the green button and up hold the
majority committee recommendation of
ought to pass thank you mr speaker
the question before us is the majority
report about to pass as amended on house
bill 1382
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
me
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
177 voting 157 voting native committee
reports adopted
majority of the committee on children
and family law to which was referred
house bill 1396 f it
an act relative to the payment of child
support have been considered the same
report the same with the reform
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senator deborah desimone
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and be an
honorable degree with the majority
report the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass from senator patrick long
for the minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion mr speaker stage of
motion
i make a motion to table house bill 1396
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is
to table house bill 1396.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
as opposed to say nay
the eyes help it
and house bill 1396 is laid on the table
majority of committee on children and
family law to which was referred house
bill 1416
and act relative to
to consent for mental health treatment
and parenting cases and with shared
decision-making responsibility have been
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator josh ocala
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate president of
cody belanger for the minority of the
committee
the
amendment the amendment is
0871 h printed in house record 10 a page
56.
are you ready for the
amendment are you ready for the question
on the amendment all those in favor say
aye
those oppose nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted
for what reason is a member eyes
thank you mr speaker i rise to table um
hb 1416.
that is a proper motion
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1416.
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
will take your seats
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1416.
this is going to be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
blanchard for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
i ask that we table this so that it can
go i'm sorry
if i know thank you sorry it's the first
time up here if i know that this bill
has unintended consequences that could
pit parents against parents
and that if i further know that this
bill should go back to the committee so
that i could continue to work on this to
find a better amendment
would i then support the tabling motion
the chair recognizes representative
simone for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know
that this bill came out of committee
14 to 1 with both sides of the aisle
agreeing that this is a good bill
then would i vote no
on the tabling motion thank you mr
speaker
the motion before us is a table house
bill 1416.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative rhodes
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
28.
305 voting nay
the tabling motion fails
we're back to the original motion about
to pass with amendment
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on children
family law to which was referred house
bill 1431 fn local an act establishing
the parental bill of rights and
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator josh ocala
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator patrick
long for the minority of the committee
the amendment is 0 8 8 1 h printed in
house record 10 a pages
56-58
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the chair recognizes
representative greeson to speak for the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
people have rights that are enumerated
in the constitution of the united states
and the state of new hampshire and
declared as unalienable
however these rights are being infringed
upon with increasing frequency in recent
years we are constantly provided
examples of bad things people do and
then there's a large contingency of
people who want to punish those who
haven't done those things because some
people did bad things for example we
constantly have to fight off attempt to
take away our firearms
because some people choose to use
firearms for nefarious purposes
now there's an escalating push to remove
the recognized inalienable rights of
parents over their children all because
some parents may be lousy parents
parents are told they shouldn't be
allowed to make decisions about their
children's education just look at the
effort to prevent education freedom
accounts in school choice
parents are told they don't have the
right to interfere with
excuse me with their children's
decisions about their medical care look
at the efforts to allow children to
obtain various medical treatments
without parental permission
parents are even losing custody of their
young children because they oppose these
decisions even the ones made by their
very young children
parents are being treated as domestic
terrorists for questioning anyone in a
position of authority
house bill 1431 sends the message to
anyone who might not understand this or
might think otherwise but children
belong to their parents and parents have
the fundamental right to determine the
care and upbringing of their children
and these rights are inalienable
at a time when the parents of new
hampshire are wondering where we stand
passing house bill 1431 would say to
them loud and clear parents we stand
with you
and although this bill explains the
rights of parents this one bill is truly
for the children thank you
the chair recognizes representative long
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the out to pass as amended
question
this bill addresses the right of
apparent singular
again which parent do these rights apply
to are court filings needed to decide
which parent on specific issues can
maintain these rights and the consensus
with the people that were testifying
were yes if there's a question between
the parents let let them go to court
as often as uh as often as witnesses in
cfl committee are unhappy parents that
are that have been to court
because the court did not side with them
so now two loving parents with the best
interests of the child are made to be in
conflict
what does this do divorce or separated
parents it rants up their ability to
conflict with one another i do recognize
that any conflict with parents is a
strain on the child and that's my main
concern here is the children
the bill also contains language in part
that reads all parental rights are
retained without obstruction or
interference from the state or other
governmental entities does this include
department of education the new
hampshire general court federal law
i believe it does
this bill weighs heavily on parental
rights specific to school districts
which are rights currently in statute in
total in testimony it was made clear
that some school districts currently
post the information being requested on
their website
so these this this is for those that
that for whatever reason are not putting
this information which is already in
statute uh to
to mandate that they do that
to put those districts that aren't
putting it on their website to put on a
website so again it's it's it's a it's a
duplication
and in my mind does this language create
a need for interpretation and
clarification on the current statutes
once this bill is passed
this bill contains a clause that would
create disciplinary action toward a
trust a trusted adult of a child i agree
that no adult should be encouraged
a child not to speak with their parents
however children often depend on trusted
adults in helping them through fast
changing times in their life whether
they be teachers coaches or mentors the
concerns are with the trusted adult not
wanting to speak to a student a fear of
retaliation for disciplinary action
although this bill contains exemptions
as it does
not authorize a parent to abuse or
neglect their child has defined in rsa
169c the concern is with all parental
rights is retained without obstruction
or interference from state or
governmental entities
does that mean dcyf is it dcyf have to
come out with a finding before they
could interfere or does the court have
to come out with a finding before it
could be interfered
so
um
could a parent not have
have to cooperate with dcyf or or the
court for that matter so in summary the
minority believes house bill 1431 will
have enough
it will not have the effect that people
are looking to change and that also this
bill is detrimental to the health and
welfare of children thank you mr speaker
division has been requested we're down
to the last speaker members take your
seats
chair recognizes representative ocala to
speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker i rise in support
of the otpa
motion
i
this this bill
addresses a lot of the concerns that we
heard in testimony which is that there
is conflicts between
parents and the state it's not between
parents this is only about the parents
between the parent between the parents
and the state where
the the state is trying to
keep information from the parents so
that they are not able to adequately
parent their kids and so this
asks that those uh like the school board
to come with with policies to to
be able to inform parents about how they
can be an active participant
how they can inspect district
instructional materials and
assessment results
and um it also
requires that state and political
officials
and school administrative
the school district and school
administrative unit
shall not encourage or
attempt
to
coerce the
minor to withhold information from their
parents where the parent is not
under investigation or not suspected of
committing a crime against those kids so
that that
they're not encouraging or putting up a
roadblock in between the parents and the
kids
and
we worked on this and that hopefully
this this will you know there's a lot of
concerns from parents we heard a lot of
testimony on this especially with
schools and and the communication with
the schools and so this
bill encourages each school board school
district and administrative school unit
to
have a policy to pro to promote parental
involvement in the public school system
so i hope you will
support this as amended thank you
mr speaker
the motion before us
[Music]
representative belanger has requested
roll calls that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
the motion before us is the majority
report of our passes amended on house
bill 1431
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
petrogrino for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that as well intended as many
believe this legislation to be
that the rights enumerated within
are already part of federal and state
statutes the department of education's
administrative directives
and many school board policies therefore
making this legislation redundant and
not necessary
and that parents who believe that their
rights have been violated already have
well established legal remedies
to address their
grievances but more so mr speaker if i
know as a former high school teacher of
40 years
that this legislation would
unintentionally
harm troubled and vulnerable children
who may not be ready for whatever reason
to confide in a parent with their deep
personal struggles
but because of this legislation would be
limited in their opportunity to do so
with a trusted adult such as a school
nurse coach guidance counselor or
teacher because these trusted adults
would fear being subject to disciplinary
action
and lastly mr speaker
if i believe that this legislation has
many unintended consequences that would
be harmful to the health and welfare of
children
would i not press the red button to vote
no that another motion may be made thank
you mr speaker chair recognizes
representative d simone for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that the government should
limit their interference in parents
ability to properly parent their
children as much as possible
and if i know that parents deserve the
transparency
and it is of utmost importance when
children are into interacting
with the government including the
schools
then i should press the green button
in support of the committee's
recommendation of ought to pass as
amended
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto pass has amended on house
bill 1431. this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
represent connors
representative connors
all members president an opportunity to
vote i also tend to say to the vote
181 voting a 157 voting a committee
report is adopted
committee on children family law to
which was referred house bill
1518fn local
an act relative to the requirements for
appointed guardians having considered
the same report the same with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment president of cody
belanger for the committee
the amendment
zero eight nine two h
printed in house record 10 a pages 76-77
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee amendment
is adopted the question before us now is
the committee report about to pass with
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
children and family law to which was
referred house bill 1612fn
and act relative to the confidentiality
of reports made to the division of
children youth and families and
requiring guardians and ad-lib to be
appointed in certain instances having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
josh o'connor for the majority of the
committee
minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
report with the following resolution
that
it be inexpedient to legislate
representative deborah altruel or for
the minority of the committee
the amendment is zero eight four two h
printed in house record 10 a page 81.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
your eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the chair recognizes
representative altrueller for to speak
against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
unlike many other states our rsa 169c
our child protective protection act
assigns
every person
in new hampshire over the age of 18
to be a mandated reporter if they
suspect a child is being abused or
neglected
this is to ensure that our children are
safe and protected and that immediate
interventions can take place if they are
in danger
the department of youth and families
report line
and if you have your pen out
is 800-894-5533
that number is staffed 24 hours a day
seven days a week i'm sure many of you
heard
that calls declined sharply during the
early days of the pandemic when children
were not able to attend school daycare
clubs sports
the calls that come into the dcyf report
line
come in from teachers they come in from
coaches
nurses doctors
librarians
dance instructors theater directors bus
drivers neighbors who carpool those
children to activities
grocery store workers and many times the
family members of the children who are
being abused or neglected
children who are being sexually abused
may disclose to a trusted adult
that trusted adult could be their
teacher
or their favorite cousin who's home from
college
a neighbor could make a call to the
report line after hearing violent
fighting
threats
hearing property damage things being
destroyed where children are present
the amazon delivery driver whose
frequent deliveries to a place causes
them to suspect that a child is being
trafficked
these examples are just a small window
into the reasons someone could make a
report because they are deeply concerned
for a child
as our law states reports made under
this statute
are presumed to be done in good faith
and can be done with anonymity
the committee received testimony that
sometimes
those reports come from right inside the
house where the abuse is happening
victims trapped in domestic violence
make reports to dcyf
against their abuser who also abuses
their children
reports come from grandparents who have
witnessed abuse on their grandchildren
many people experiencing domestic
violence at home have made reports about
their own family members
this bill
this bill would take the anonymity away
from those people seeking help
potentially endangering them further
worse still it will stop people from
making reports all together for fear of
potentially lethal retribution from the
abuser
the reports made to the department of
children family youth children youth and
families
currently can be made anonymously
but
if after further investigation
an investigation results in a court case
all of that information is revealed
in discovery
it's not anonymous forever
this bill inserts chilling language that
gives abusers permission
and gives abusers leverage to sue people
who are making reports to protect abused
children
in fact
some of the language in this bill
would require the child protection
workers on the dcyf reporting line
to say to a person reporting suspected
child abuse
who call with suspected child sexual
abuse physical abuse or trafficking
that the possibility that their name
address and phone number will be made
public
if the complaint is determined to be
made maliciously
what's not in this legislation
is who makes that determination
we don't know
it isn't clearly defined in this
language it's just hanging out there
the neighbor who had previously been
empowered and required by law
to call in to report of suspected
domestic abuse
may now
be situationally deaf
because now that abuser could come after
them too
the favorite teacher
the favorite cousin who's home from
college
will now have to weigh the possibility
of also being abused by that child's
abuser through a civil court process
and the most terrifying
the threat
that an adult on the receiving end of
violent abuse who tries to use the dcyf
reporting line to help them protect
their own children
may now also have to fear that they will
be blamed not believed or further
retaliated against by their abuser it is
imperative
that we recognize the co-occurrence of
child abuse and domestic violence
this legislation could potentially place
victims and their children at risk for
further harm
being able to make reports safely to
dcyf
regarding suspected or known child abuse
is an important part of responding to
and assisting families escape
violent and abusive situations
if passed house bill 1612
has dangerous implications for the
protections of abused children in new
hampshire
colleagues
please
press the red button so another motion
can be made thank you
we're down to the last speaker this is
going to be a division vote so members
take your seats
[Music]
the chair recognizes representative
ocala speak for the
majority committee report
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of
16 12 as amended
i have to disagree with the previous
speaker on many of the points as they
were addressed by the amendment
um the amendment
that we have adopted says that reports
to the department may
be
include the name it does not say shall
so therefore the anonymous reporting is
still possible and so
i disagree with that statement and i
also disagree with the statement that
the people's information can be released
in uh court unless if in cases where
they haven't been um
uh
they made the the um
the complaint in
uh good faith now read directly from the
bill under no circumstance
shall
the identity of the complaint
plainland who makes the report of a
suspected uh abuse or neglect in good
faith or pursuing pursuant to rsa 169c
colon 29 shall be released
so i just disagree with pretty much
everything that the previous speaker
said and i hope that you will agree with
me and vote this bill ought to pass as
amended thank you
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of what the pass has
amended on house bill 1612
this is a division vote members will
take your seats
the chair recognizes representative
petrigano for a parliamentary inquiry
those italian names are a killer mr
speaker
petrino thank you
mr speaker
if i know that under the child
protection statute
every person in new hampshire over the
age of 18 is mandated to report if they
suspect child abuse and neglect
and as the law states that such reports
are presumed to be made in good faith
if i further know mr speaker that many
people who experience domestic violence
have made anonymous reports against
family members
and that this bill would take away their
anonymity thus potentially endangering
them further worse still
it would stop abused people from making
reports altogether for fear of potential
retribution from their abusers
mr speaker if i believe that this bill
has dangerous implications
for the protection of abused children
would i not press the red button to vote
no
so that another motion may be made thank
you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative belanger
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that i
had a conversation with the director of
dcyf who supports this bill would i then
press the green button thank you
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass that amendment
as amended on house bill 1612
this is going to be a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed to press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
175 voting a 161 voting a committee
report is adopted
committee on children of family law to
which was referred house bill 1614 fn
an act requiring the recording and
storaging of digital video in all
state-funded juvenile detention
facilities having considered the same
report the same with the sen with the
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative cody
blanchard for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred house bill 1019
an act establishing a committee to study
the replacement of certain professional
licenses with the mandatory minimum
liability insurance requirements having
considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study senator max aberson from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate president
christie bartlett from the minority of
the committee
chair recognizes representative bartlett
to speak against the committee report
good morning mr speaker and colleagues
i rise to speak against the interim
steady motion
i realize there isn't a great deal of
difference between the two motions of
interim study and inexpedient to
legislate
having an insurance background however i
usually take the opportunity to inform
anyone who will listen as to how
insurance work
works as it's a mystery to so many
insurance is for the sudden and
unexpected occurrence
the premium pays for the underwriting
administrative costs and mostly for
paying claims
the premiums of the many pay the claims
of the few
the premiums are based on the cost to
provide insurance coverage not to
determine competency or compliance with
state regulations
this bill would study the multitude of
licenses that are regulated by the state
with the purpose of replacing a license
with a mandatory minimum limit of inch
liability liability insurance
liability is roughly equivalent to
negligence which would need to be
present for a claim to be paid if bodily
injury or property damage occurs
insurance only pays for the resulting
loss and does not cover workmanship
as the chair of our committee often
states we give people licenses so we can
take them away when they do something
wrong
so if there are regulatory bodies that
review license applications for
competency and compliance with statutes
would insurance be an adequate
substitute for determining competency
for instance
an electrician
would we want to if for an electrician
we would want to eliminate that
licensing requirement and just replace
it with an insurance policy for twenty
five thousand dollars
the electrician wires a home and the
home burns down due to negligence
the most the insurance policy will pay
is twenty five thousand dollars plus
defense costs
would the state have any obligation for
further action under this proposal to
replace licensing with insurance
if this was a requirement there would
have to be a significant increase in
premiums which i doubt is the purpose of
the sponsor
if the purpose of this bill is to reduce
the number of licenses required by the
state
another action should be taken than to
require a mandatory insurance policy
i won't belabor the point but i ask you
to consider opposing the interim study
so a motion of inexpedient to legislate
could be brought forward and thanks for
listening to insurance 101
chair i recognized the representative
abramson to speak for the committee
report
thank you mr speaker i rise in favor of
the refer for interim study motion from
the committee on house bill 1019
professional licensing requirements have
grown in america from eight percent of
occupations to 30 percent of occupations
and rising professional licensing
restrictions are now recognized as one
of the great underreported contributors
to poverty and child poverty in america
americans for prosperity
well you don't understand you don't
understand
americans for prosperity new hampshire
liberty alliance and the cato institute
all warn about the unintended harm to
workers of lost jobs fewer professional
services and reduced economic growth the
new hampshire republican platform
promises voters
before the election that we quote
minimize business regulations permits
licensing regulations and paperwork
please press the green button so that we
can study this issue in september
the question before us
is the majority report of interim study
on house bill 1019
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
kills opposed nay
the eyes have it
and the committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on commerce
and consumer affairs to which has
referred house bill 1028 fn and act
relative to the form of individual
health insurance policies having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study president max
abramson and the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
joyce weston for the minority of the
committee
the motion before us is the report the
report of referred for interim study on
house bill 1028 fn are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it and the committee
report is adopted
mr speaker this is
majority of committee on commerce and
consumer affairs to which was referred
house bill 1380 and act relative to the
installation of solar profile
baltic
energy systems by owners subject to deed
restrictions in a homeowners association
been considered the same report the same
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislation of
john hunt for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same report the same
being unable to agree with the majority
report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass
president of constance van houghton for
the minority of the committee
this is going to be a division vote we
only have pis members take your seats
okay
so
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of any speed into
legislation on house bill 1380 this is
going to be a division vote the chair
recognizes representative bolio for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that solar energy is efficient
and environmentally friendly and if i
know
that many homeowners associations are
operating under documents
that are decades old with a limited
mechanisms for change
and that this bill would simplify
render
sections about solar installation
unenforceable
and finally if i know that this bill is
enabling
and not a mandate
and that would just open the door for
owners in homeowners associations who
own their own buildings
and land to install solar energy systems
then would i push the red button
to overturn the motion of inexpedient to
legislate
on hb 1380 so that another motion can be
made
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
patuck for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
despite the co
contention
that this bill is enabling and not
mandatory it will require any homeowners
association
to permit a solar panel to be placed on
a homeowner's home the member will
suspend this is a parliamentary inquiry
i'm sorry sir
okay 1380. okay thank you mr speaker
if i know that any homeowner and
homeowners association can have solar
collectors if their fellow members of
their homeowners association agree
would i now press the green button to
vote yes for any expedient to legislate
speaker the motion before us is the
majority committee report have been
expedient to legislator on house bill
1380. this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
okay
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
200 voting 131 voting a committee report
is adopted
the committee on commerce which was
referred house bill 1413
an act relative to privacy of online
customer information having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate
representative joyce weston for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative max abramson for the
minority of the committee
member from seabrook representative
abramson is recognized to speak against
the committee report
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker this bill was
introduced to us by a number of
republicans it was a partisan
bill to be fair but it was a republican
platform bill
this bill simply prevents internet
service providers from selling or
disclosing your personal information and
web browsing history to multinational
corporations foreign governments
advertisers and increasingly orwellian
federal agencies the republican platform
calls on us to quote protect the privacy
of individuals from government agencies
and employees who abuse their power and
position unquote the voters of this
state just a few years ago passed a
measure by a margin of about 10 to 1
adding the right to privacy to our state
constitution
we were assured at the hearing that
internet service providers hadn't yet
given away your browsing history
passwords personal information bandwidth
usage statistics and the number of
connected devices in your home yet
i'm currently studying cyber security
and contrary to the majority report
internet service providers definitely do
have access to the internet traffic
about you your home and everything
related to your i p and mac addresses
again we are told not to do anything
about these potential abuses because no
one knows
about actual abuses yet do we wait for
crimes to happen before we legislate
against them do we wait for bridges to
collapse before we repair them do we
wait for inflation to get out of control
before we tighten down on the money
supply
do we wait until aids kills 800 000
americans before implementing harm
reduction measures
well yes but the right thing to have
done would have been to prevent these
problems before they had occurred red
button
the member from plymouth representative
weston is recognized to speak in support
of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
there
there is no reason to
oppose this bill
i'm sorry i was rather unprepared for
this
the the
online information cannot be shared by
the um
shoot i'm sorry i'm going to wave on
this i'm sorry
the question before the house is the
majority committee report of an
expedient to legislate on house bill
1413 representative abramson requests a
roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
this will be a division vote members
take your seats
here
members of the house uh a button was
inadvertently hit to update display and
it's right next to the lock all member
desks uh button so please just turn your
stations back on nothing nefarious
happened i promise
the house will come to order
representative abramson is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i do
know that your internet service provider
does have access to literally all of
your web traffic
by definition
if i know that this simple bill attempts
to prevent internet service providers
from knowingly or intentionally giving
that information away
when requested by
spy agencies or even foreign companies
or foreign corporations if i know
that
some internet service providers want
legal protections like this so that they
don't have to comply
with requirements even by foreign
divisions within their own company would
i press the red button
representative potack is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that internet service providers also
known as isps
have no access to anyone's personal data
and the bill conflicts with federal
privacy requirements for isps would i
now press the green button to vote yes
for expedient to legislate thank you mr
speaker
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpediential
legislate this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll be pressing the
green button if you're opposed you'll be
pressing the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
so
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
289 having voted in the affirmative 47
and the negative the committee report
has adopted
the majority of the committee on
commerce and consumer affairs which was
referred house bill 1503 fn
an act exempting the developer seller or
facilitator of the exchange of an open
blockchain token from certain securities
laws having considered the same report
the same with the following amendment
and the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment
representative keith ammon for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative joyce
weston for the minority of the committee
the committee report is zero eight two
eight h printed on house record 10 a
pages 66 to 75. the questions on the
committee amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question now is on the
for reason as a member rise
mr speaker i rise to make a motion
my motion is to move to table on 1503.
i also request a division vote
the motion is to lay house bill 1503 on
the table division votes been requested
members please take receipts
who requested a roll call
representative osborne requests for roll
calls that's officially it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members still please take
your seats
okay
c
all right the house will come to order
representative van houghton is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill is premature
because amended drafts and the results
of both state and federal commissions on
the subject will be coming out very
shortly in just a few months but i now
push the green button to table this bill
to await further information thank you
representative osborne is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that
while we have a lot of work to do this
week this is probably going to be the
most interesting debate we're going to
hear all week would i now press the
red button
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1503 on the table this is a roll
call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
149 having voted in the affirmative 188
and the negative the motion the table
fails
the member from manchester
representative herbert is recognized to
speak against the committee report
representative you've
thank you mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the
proposed bill
um
it's really a pretty dramatic
vote
today i would i would think this is
maybe the most dramatic vote of the
house
uh
in this session
uh the bill uh
wants to establish
a bitcoin
cryptocurrency
and legitimize it
and it and in as a result of that
it will change
about 500 years worth of banking
banking that we know it westphalian
banking is what it's called
and that was where
the nation state
has
sovereignty
and um
cryptocurrency the cryptocurrency
ecology
is based on secrecy
and anonymity
and as a result will be a direct
competitor
to the banking establishment that we
were
that is almost 500 years old so it's not
a unimportant
insignificant
bill that we're discussing
the cryptocurrency ecology
is the preferred
financial
system
for organized crime around the world
it was
designed for that purpose
and it's very good at it as a matter of
fact
it makes it very difficult
for
law enforcement to
enforce the law it's very difficult to
find out
who's selling what and who's buying what
because secrecy is
is its calling card
um some promoters of the ecosystem
maintain that they there will eventually
be a public ledger
and that would be a westphalian type of
thing where the there is a third party
that uh oversees and records
what goes on in the cryptocurrency
environment
but that is not a certain certainty that
is uh that is an opinion it's it's
normative it that is not a a positive
statement we don't know exactly how
that's going to happen
and in fact there are a lot of
a lot of
faults and weaknesses
that will
make it very very hard
for us to have a public ledger
which would which would allow us to see
who's buying what and who's selling what
and
and what is what
it's the interesting thing the most
it was said that this is the wild west
they
make that connection they say it's just
like the wild west only except this is
in finance
unfortunately there's some accuracy
there but i think it falls short of
actually
telling us what the difficulties are
going to be like
cryptocurrency has a unique feature that
allows it to be
everywhere
and nowhere
at the same time
so you can see the difficulties we were
going to have
if this bill ever becomes law
there is going to be a very very hard
pushback
against this kind of legislation for the
reasons that people are concerned that
the nation state
the sovereignty of the nation state
will be compromised
and
as a matter of fact the cryptocurrency
ecology
is being used today
to get around some of the sanctions
that the united states has put forward
on russia
because of its invasion of the ukraine
and we can't do anything about it
because
this cryptocurrency ecology
is well established around the world
so
if the united states says well we don't
want to have the bitcoin china has
already done that that doesn't matter
there will be a mining facility and an
exchange facility put in another country
and already there is this this ecology
is very well established
i'm afraid i may be this may be the
pandora's box
it's opened
and so now we have a situation where the
mon
the sovereignty of the united states
monetary system is going to be
compromised
as will other nation
states so for that those reasons and
there are a lot of different reasons
uh in addition to that it's not as
foolproof as the 51 rule somebody can
actually get 51
of the bitcoin and that
basically allows them to
attack
any state
effort that might be made
so it's it's very problematic i think at
minimum it needs to be studied
i'm not saying that it can't work
i'm just saying the concerns are real
and there are no answers that satisfy my
standards
to put this into to legitimize this
particular
financial system
so i urge you to
put it on hold or don't pass it for
heaven's sake but
if i was the governor i would have fired
the banking commissioner by now
and uh
and let's list it needs to study
and i think we can do that
and maybe we can come up with something
that will actually
get the best
of bitcoin
uh without the compromises of uh ruining
the sovereignty of the nation states
thank you
does the member yield for a question
normally i'd say no timmy but okay i'll
take it
you may inquire
thank you for taking my question um
you know i was just reading through the
bill and i'm curious if your
interpretation is the same as mine the
the plain text language in this bill
would seem to read like it would allow a
financial institution
to simply get involved with blockchain
stuff and exempt all of their operations
from these security laws that are cited
and it doesn't seem to only exempt their
blockchain operations from the
securities laws so is there anything in
this legislation that's going to prevent
some other bank or day trader
or some other existing financial
institution from just selling a bitcoin
to exempt themselves from all of the
state's financial statutes
i would say that's possible
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done to tighten up
uh regulation to protect our sovereignty
here in the united states and any nation
state
the westphalian system has been around
for five centuries
and it's not perfect
as we all know
banks
banks collapse and capitalists
fall over and you know socialists get
authoritarian on us
you know so that there are a lot of
problems in in the banking system
that exists today
but it has
gotten through
five centuries bitcoin is significantly
different
than the system we have now
i'm not comfortable
with it at all
and there are i think
criminals are always way ahead of the
government
when something new comes along
so uh
we need to we need to work a lot harder
on this and
and not be so
libertarian if you will
and see if we can't get something that
will actually work thank you
the member from seabrook representative
abramson is recognized to speak in
support of the committee report
thank you mr speaker house bill 1503 and
the language in it was discussed for a
long time at the universal
commerce commission our own uh
convention of the states that's held
every year in chicago
h.b 1503 would exempt holders of
blockchain tokens from certain
securities roles as they are not trading
in securities several other states are
moving including wyoming are moving
through similar legislation to attract
business holders of these keys similar
to the online safe deposit boxes
and we need to attract new business and
new industries by protecting new
startups from onerous regulations that
lenders currently face
after all these companies are not
lenders they don't have access to the
contents of the blockchain and are
innovating in the field of protecting
bitcoin litecoin doggy coin and other
new technologies recently
coinbase has just announced that they
are now blocking access to over 25 000
russian coinbase accounts that means
that this foreign exchange site
has arbitrary power to take away
anyone's access to their own
cryptocurrency
on a whim or even close off access to
altcoins that are used for other
purposes such as storing information
patents official documents news articles
or proof of ownership or authorship
while new hampshire currently has no
applications for registered blockchain
tokens yet consumers clearly need more
options for this newly developed
technology than what is currently out
there green button
the member from plymouth representative
weston is recognized to speak against
the committee report
thank you mr speaker
colleagues i'm going to provide you with
some solid reasons to oppose this bill
as we amended it this morning
to respond to representative smith
i don't have trouble with the first part
of the amended bill which exempts the
blockchain token from security laws
under certain circumstances
but i do have a problem with the second
part of the bill which is to adopt
article 12 of the uniform commercial
code known as the ucc
why do i object to this new article
because we don't know yet what's in it
in our committee hearings we were given
a draft which was drafted in december of
last year
and i had some serious problems with
certain elements of that draft
even the uniform law commission the
group writing these laws admitted that
there were issues with the draft
amendment 0828 which we just voted on
includes updated rules from the ulc
and those were an improvement but those
rules are still a draft
the commission is meeting again this
spring
to work on the issue further and the
final product is promised to come
sometime this summer
so my question is what's the hurry
i don't know about you but i would not
write a blank check nor would i sign a
contract without reading it
meanwhile on february 9th governor
sununu submitted the executive order
establishing a commit a commission
on cryptocurrencies and digital assets
he's pulling in all the experts to
explore this complex issue
and the reports due out on august 8th
that's only five months from now
is it really appropriate for us to jump
ahead
of that the results of that commission
then on march 9th just last week
president biden signed an executive
order
to call on the federal government in
coordination with the federal reserve
to examine the risks and benefits of
cryptocurrencies
the measures in his upcoming study
focused on six key areas
consumer protection
financial stability
illicit activity
us competitiveness
financial inclusion
and responsible innovation
in our brief commerce hearings
we didn't touch on half of that
there's a lot more to consider here than
what we had in our brief commerce
hearings
so wouldn't it be prudent for us to wait
for these reports
they should be out this year they're
coming out in the second half of 2022.
the other thing i wanted to mention is
that we're approaching the
78th anniversary of the bretton woods
conference
i'm really proud that the american
dollar has maintained its role as a
standard for reserve currencies since
1944.
i recognize that we need to establish
rules
to contain the threat of a second
currency in our economy
but right now i think we need to slow
down let the experts do their work and
then proceed with caution
so please hit the red button
to stop this blind and premature
acceptance of an unfinished bill
and i request a division vote
final speaker
the member from new boston
representative amman is recognized to
speak in support of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
five years ago i was before this body
talking about cryptocurrency and uh
saying it was going to be a big deal
it's going to be as big a deal as the
internet
and you know maybe not many people
believed me back then but
you can see
[Music]
our other speaker mentioned that the
governor issued an executive order
the president of the united states
issued an executive order both to create
a commission
to study so it is a big deal
what this bill does is it
implements the result of another
commission and it's called the uniform
law commission
and they have a draft it's called
article 12. and it is
the uniform commercial code on emerging
technologies
and this draft
the current bill is a glide path to
implement this
new article of the ucc
we would be the first state to do it now
uniform commercial code
is designed to
help interstate commerce it's it's
state-level law that lots of states
adopt
rsa 382 of our new hampshire rsas we
have adopted articles one through nine
with the exception of article six which
is now obsolete
so article 12 is going to deal with new
technologies
we're currently in something called the
fourth industrial revolution you may
have heard of the industrial revolution
the first was steam and water power the
second was the locomotive
the telegraph and the electrification
the third was the digital revolution
with computers
we're in the fourth
industrial revolution and
you may have heard the expression that
data is the new oil
what
controllable electronic records
controllable electronic records it's
kind of an abstraction of multiple
things
and that's what the uniform commercial
code article 12 deals with these are the
building blocks
of the future of the global economy
and they're things like digital assets
you've heard of cryptocurrencies
they're things like stable coins that
are
tied to the u.s dollar the u.s dollar
currently is
represents 97 of all stable coins
so cryptocurrency is giving the u.s
dollar the biggest market
globally so it doesn't undermine the
dollar it actually enhances it
you may have heard of nfts and
non-fungible tokens
electronic promissory notes so these are
things like smart contracts that can you
can automate
financial transactions
these are big topics i'm happy to talk
for hours with any of you uh
afterwards
but keep in mind this is a trillion
dollar global industry
by new hampshire being the first to
adopt ucc article 12
we will be ahead of the pack will
attract
entrepreneurs innovators
young young engineers that are
interested in this topic to our state
and that is the benefit of adopting this
bill so i ask you to support
the the bill as amended and vote green
does the member yield for a question
i do
represent perez inquirer
thank you for taking my question
do you know
by any chance other countries have been
using this currency already and they've
been benefiting from
even having a bitcoin city
are you talking about el salvador yes
yeah so the country of el salvador has
uh adopted bitcoin as
uh
in their legal tender laws so you can
buy if i understand correctly you can
buy coffee and so forth
there's a lot of complaint about uh
mining the mining process of bitcoin
using electricity using too much energy
but in el salvador they're actually
using geothermal energy from a volcano
for this for the country to mine bitcoin
and they're developing bonds for the
country based on uh the output of that
mining is that what you're asking yes
okay thank you thank you for answering
my question
thank you
the question is on the majority
committee report about to pass as
amended are you ready for the question
who requested the roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is this will be a roll call vote
members please take your seats
the house will come to order
representative fargo is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that understanding the
consequences of using cryptocurrency and
digital assets at a national and state
level takes time and effort and that
these assets can be extremely volatile
investment and with serious scalability
issues
and if i know the president signed an
executive order last wednesday to study
digital assets on a federal level while
the uniform commercial code or the ucc
council is still working on article 12
and will be making more changes when
they meet again in june
and if i know that we will have the
report from the governor's commission in
august a commission that was established
to deal with these assets in a safe and
responsible way so that new hampshire
can continue to advance necessary
reforms promote economic growth foster
innovation and meet the changing
customer needs while ensuring safety
soundness and consumer protection
and finally if i know that passing this
legislation today is premature
we do not need to be first in the nation
on this technology
and an alternative solution of interim
study would allow us to have
all the information from the federal
government the governor's commission and
the latest ucc amendments to enable us
to move forward progressively
then would i oppose the ought to pass as
amended by pressing the red button so we
can
introduce another motion
representative edwards is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that had i
followed the vision of our
representative from new boston five
years ago i'd be
filthy rich
and
if i knew that this bill would help put
new hampshire in the leader position and
these emerging financial technologies
and that in turn
would
indicate to the world that new hampshire
is in fact seen as tech friendly
and that that would therefore create
a new clean industry that would bring in
new engineering and investor roles into
the state if i knew those things would i
green light
this bill by pressing the green button
the question is the majority committee
report of octopass is amended
if you're in favor you'll be pressing
the green button if you're opposed
you'll be pressing the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
so
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
187 having voted the affirmative 150 on
the negative the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
commerce and consumer affairs just
referred house bill 1583 fn
an act relative to locations and days of
operation of state liquor stores having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative john
hunt for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
max abramson for the minority of the
committee
the committee amendment is zero eight
three eight h printed on house record 10
a on pages 79-80 the question is on the
committee amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question now is on the majority
committee report about to pass as
amended the member from seabrook
representative abramson is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the majority report about
to pass with amendment on
representative oregon's bill
hb 1583 hb 1583 would allow state liquor
stores to be open on easter sunday
christmas and thanksgiving
and to open up right next to churches
chapels and parish houses
yet we were told at public hearings that
the liquor stores
can't find workers who will leave the
family at church or supper on these
three hallow days of thanks prayer and
reflection
an improbable and negligible amount of
state revenue did not seem reason enough
to open up liquor stores on the holiest
of days nor to disturb the quiet
enjoyment of families
who might not see each other
on the more hectic 362 days a year
if there's no revenue to be gained why
introduce the bill
what does it purport to accomplish
anyone so desperate for hard liquor but
poor of planning ought to accept their
fate on easter sunday and acquiesce to
the great variety of beer and wine in
our many private sector stores
the ten commandments warns us to honor
the sabbath and keep it holy
in this increasingly noisy distracted
hectic world can't we reserve
three holidays a year honoring the birth
of our nation the birth of our savior
and the hope of everlasting life
three days of quiet enjoyment by our
families the republican platform
recognizes the importance of faith and
so should we red button
the member from derry representative
potter check is recognized to speak in
support of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
as introduced this bill changes the
regulation on places of operation of the
state liquor stores and allows state
liquor stores to be open on easter
the committee amendment replaces the
original bill and removes references to
any one holiday
the current law allows the liquor
commission to open on holidays with the
agreement from the state employees
already working there
so removing actual days from the statute
seems more appropriate
thank you mr speaker
representative abramson has requested a
division vote
this will be a division vote members
please take receipts
the question is on the majority
committee report of ought to pass with
amendment this is a division vote
representative abramson is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that the state-run liquor stores
are state-run that that's us that we
have only one government that it's not a
private company
if i know that easter sunday christmas
and thanksgiving are three of the most
hallowed
days of the year in our culture
and if i know that for many families
these three days or only one of them are
the only days that they can sit down for
quiet reflection and thanks
for what we have as a country would i
now press the red button and support the
republican platform
representative potick is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i believe in k-i-s-s keeping it short
and simple
and not have any particular religious
holidays in the rsas
would i now press the green button to
vote yes
for ought to pass with amendment thank
you mr speaker
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass as amended this is
a division vote if you're in favor
you'll be pressing the green button if
you're opposed you'll be pressing the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
of all members presidents had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
278 having voted in the affirmative 58
in the negative the committee reports
adopted
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred cacr20
an act relating to personal liberty
providing that adults shall have the
right to possess cannabis for personal
consumption having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
dave testament for the majority of the
committee
for what reason does a member rise
thank you mr speaker i'd like to make a
motion to table cacr20
representative abbas moves that
cacr20 be laid on the table are you
ready for the question
division has been requested this will be
a division vote members take your seats
the question is whether to lay crca 20
on the table this is a division vote
representative abramson is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker if i know
that this proposal would simply ask the
voters to consider amending the state
constitution to
to get the state out of the issue of
cannabis entirely if i know that we've
worked on this issue and these three
bills in particular for a very long time
and if i know
that the other bills that have been
mentioned uh we have no idea what's
going to happen to them and and those
other bills should not influence your
decision on a tabling motion would i now
press the red button to vote down the
tabling motion
representative abbas is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that cacr
20 would allow an unlimited amount of
possession of cannabis for personal use
and mr speaker alaska if i know that if
such a
constitutional amendment was adopted it
would make it very difficult to ever
implement any type of recreational
program with any type of regulations
so i go ahead and push that green button
and support that motion to table thank
you mr speaker
the question is whether lay crca 20 on
the table this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll be pressing the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
165 having voted in the affirmative 166
and the negative the motion fails
the house will come to order
the question is on the majority
committee report of an expediential
legislate the member from seabrook
representative abramson is recognized to
speak against the committee report
landslide
you want me to start
do you want me to start
the house will come to order the member
has a right to be heard
rep the member from seabrook
representative abramson is recognized to
speak against the committee report
all right i'll be short
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i rise
against the itl
motion on cacr
r20 the war on drugs has been a war on
marijuana
at one point 85 percent of arrests and
as many as incarcerated
on drug arrests and and drug
laws were serving time for marijuana
possession
88 percent of those as we heard in
committee
were black latino or american indian
most of these americans are in fact
caged and forced to work for literal or
nothing literal literal slavery
my ancestors fought and died in the
civil war to end black slavery yet it's
come back in this form of this insane
war on drugs incarceration of
non-violent drug and gun offenders puts
poor and brown americans behind bars to
be used as actual prison slave labor
mr speaker as frederick douglass said
and as i have said on this floor many
times taxation of wages is slavery
taxing our constituents at the rate of
54 386 dollars per year per pot smoker
accomplishes nothing
but the breakdown in respect for the
rule of law and the breakdown of our
families we cannot arrest our way out of
this problem red button
the member from dover representative
conley is recognized to speak against
the committee report
thank you mr speaker colleagues i rise
against the motion of an expedient to
legislate new hampshire voters
overwhelmingly support legalizing
cannabis
yet the legislature has failed to make
good on their wishes
this bill would let voters decide
whether or not to legalize recreational
cannabis using the constitutional
amendment process
with a simple yes or no vote residents
could or could consider this simple
question
all adults shall have the right to
possess cannabis intended for their
personal consumption that's it that's
what this would do
if it passes the issue would almost
certainly come back to this chamber to
set some reasonable guard rails for how
it would work
if it fails we could put this issue to
rest once and for all for a few years
let's put it to voters and see what they
say thank you
representative abbas is recognized to
speak in support of the committee report
the last speaker
thank you mr speaker
and i'll repeat myself
this
cacr cacr20 would allow
any individual who granted the
constitutional right to possess as much
cannabis as they want without any
restriction
provided it's intended for its personal
use
there's no definition of that it's just
that's how it is all the
bills that we've worked very hard on in
a bipartisan manner would all be deemed
unconstitutional we would have to start
over from scratch this would be a step
backwards and with that being said we
have two other caacrs to follow this on
the same subject
cannabis
and i'll say this time and carry it over
is the state constitution the best place
to
put can't list cannabis or marijuana
policies
i believe not
so please join me and push the green
button to support the committee's
recommendation of index being to
legislate thank you mr speaker
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on cacr20 are you ready for
the question
all those in favor say aye
all those oppo
we've had a request for a division this
will be a division vote members take
your seats
the house will come to order
the question is on the majority com
yeah majority committee report of
inexpedience to legislate on cacr 20.
representative espise speeches
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i believe that the issue of cannabis
has been discussed for for years now and
that
it is popular amongst many of our
constituents
and if i believe that
the prime sponsor of this bill
our former colleague from from hampton
worked incredibly hard on this issue for
so many years and
if i believe that
for i if i believe this is a steep issue
to put it on the constitutional as a
constitutional amendment but that
it may be time to give it to the voters
then would i now vote to overturn the
itl the cacr
representative apis is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that
cacr20
would allow any adult
which i presume is over the age of 18
because it doesn't say 21 to possess an
unlimited amount of cannabis
and mr speaker lastly lastly if i know
that if the federal prohibition were to
ever be removed and i certainly hope it
does one day
that
the likely age of regulation be 21
similar to alcohol and tobacco
and therefore this constitutional
amendment would conflict with
potential future federal law would i go
ahead and push that green button to
support the committee's recommendation
of ix being to legislate thank you mr
speaker
the questions on the majority committee
report of and expedient to legislate
if you are in favor you'll be pressing
the green button if you're opposed
you'll be pressing the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
214 having voted in the affirmative 121
in the negative the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred cacr34
and act relating to the use sale or
cultivation of cannabis providing that
the state shall make no law prohibiting
the use sale or cultivation of cannabis
for persons over 18 years of age having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that it
is inexpedient to legislate
representative dave testerman for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative chris true for the
minority of the committee for what
reason does the member rise
thank you mr speaker i rise to make a
motion to table cacr34
representative abbas moves that cacr34
be laid on the table are you ready for
the question
somebody request a division division
vote has been requested this will be a
division vote members please take your
seats
the question is whether it'll lay cr30
cacr34
on the table this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll be pressing the
green button if you're opposed you'll be
pressing the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
so
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
266 having voted in the affirmative 68
in the negative cser 34 is laid on the
table
majority committee on criminal justice
and public safety to which was referred
cacr35
it's awful noisy in here
an act relating to cannabis providing
that all adults have the right to
possess use and cultivate cannabis
subject to regulation by the legislature
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate as an of dave testament from
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with john burt for the
minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
thank you mr speaker i rise to make a
motion uh to table cacr35
that is a
proper motion the motion before us is
the table cacr35
are you ready for the question all
division has been requested members take
their seats
the motion before us is to table cacr35
this is going to be a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
no
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the vote
260 voting a 75 voting a the table in
motion passes
thank you
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred house bill
1004 fn
act relative to penalties for failure to
provide information after an animal
injury we consider the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
senator harriet garth right for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
majority of committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which has
referred house bill 1017 fn
enact establishing criminal penalties
for harming or threatening to harm an
essential worker having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpending
to legislate senator john byrd for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same we'd been unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass was in a very newman for the
minority of the committee
question before us is the majority
reported in expediting the legislature
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes haven't the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 1072
an act establishing a criminal penalty
for denying an elected school district
official access to any school district
facilities documents or events having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment president of terry
roy from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator ray
newman for the minority of the committee
for what member reason does a member
rise
uh to make a motion mr speaker stage of
motion
i motion to table
house bill 1072
it is a proper motion the motion before
us is the table house bill 107.2
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently second that is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members take your seats
we're just getting here now
updated
team
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on house bill 1072
this is going to be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes
representative allard for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that we have not
yet sufficiently addressed issues of
privacy and safety for students and
staff in our schools
and if i know that
we further
have not addressed limitations for
things like
employee personnel files
and if i know mr speaker that we should
not advance any bill from this house
that has not sufficiently addressed its
concerns would i now press the green
button and support the tabling motion
chair recognize representative steve
pearson for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that this
bill prevents the silencing
of political detractors by school
officials
and mr speaker if i know this does not
allow any access to anything that is
prohibited currently by state or federal
law and finally mr speaker if i know
that this enables elected officials to
properly conduct their jobs
for the people that elected them to do
it what i now press the red button
to defeat this tabling motion thank you
the motion before us is to table house
bill 107.2 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
uh if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
169 voting a 161 vote in a the motion to
table passes
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 1085
i would hope that
this noise level does not continue for
the rest of the day
enact relative to ignition lock
requirements having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass presenter
manny espedia for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
able to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislative
president linda harriet garth wright for
the minority of the committee
the question before us is the majority
report about to pass
on house bill 1085 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
we're going to be taking our lunch break
now but before anybody leaves let me uh
let me
clarify where we're at
on friday we learned that the statehouse
cafeteria would be closed for the week
many of you utilize that service before
because it is so close convenient very
good food
so for lunch today to accommodate those
of you who don't want to go off campus
we have complementary pizza downstairs
in the cafeteria
the pizza is made possible by the
generosity of the sponsors the new
hampshire homebuilders association and
legislative solutions
please be sure to thank them
we do have a limited quantity so we're
going to ask you to take one slice at a
time
and make sure everyone who wants a piece
can do so
pizza will be served this this is
really
pretty pretty important so listen this
pizza will be served on the kitchen side
of the cafeteria area
and the basement level dining room and
members lounge on the first floor are
available for seating
for those of you who choose to go off
campus
just be sure you're back here at
two o'clock
we understand tansies may have their
session day buffet there are also a
number of restaurants within walking
distance for planting purposes we
will not have a luncheon option here
tomorrow but we do plan on having food
available at dinner time
and thank you again from the new
hampshire home building association
legislative solutions
first of all i
want to thank all our lunch sponsors
today the new hampshire home builders
association and the legislative
solutions
just to reaffirm where we're at
i plan on leaving getting going till
about between six and seven tonight
hopefully about 6 30.
there will not be a lunch tomorrow
you'll be on your own for lunch tomorrow
but we do anticipate working into the
night
tomorrow and
thursday
the new hampshire auto build automobile
dealers association has stepped up to
sponsor thursday's meal for us
and
lunch will be
provided to us by the kiwanis club of
concord there'll be hot dogs and
hamburgers outside
in the uh on the front
uh but
we still have a lot of work to do
and we're gonna start at nine tomorrow
and go to at least nine o'clock or later
tomorrow night
and the same thing on thursday night
because we still have an awful lot of
bills to do
so
all right
just a minute
um so
the more cooperation that
we have the quicker this thing is going
to go
pretty much putty go ahead
thank you mr speaker i have a quick
announcement in terms of lunch
[Music]
tomorrow i have a quick announcement in
terms of lunch tomorrow i'm sponsoring a
very limited number of lunch
indian vegetarian lunch honoring the
welcoming communities
and also
our fearless
fearless leader that we last lost
recently in honoring his life and legacy
it will be individually wrapped indian
food
and it's again very limited what i could
afford to do it i'm doing it
and it will be available in room 305
upstairs thank you
uh chair recognizes the clerk for a
minute
thank you mr speaker mr speaker the
sergeant-at-arms delivered a very uh
lovely uh wallet to me and i can hear
some change in it um it's a kenneth cole
reaction
wallet it was found in the ladies room
so if you'd like to come and retrieve
your wallet please
please do so or
lunch will be on you tomorrow thanks
majority on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 1096-fn
an act prohibiting open carrying or
display of a deadly weapon within 100
feet of a polling place having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
the senate of john burt for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation the bill ought
to pass senator david muse for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative muse to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker let me start by
saying that in this country i would hope
we could agree that no american should
ever be threatened with deadly weapons
either explicitly or implicitly
while simply exercising their right to
vote
unfortunately intimidation by armed
individuals has long been a tool that
some have used to prevent the full
participation by others in our u.s
democracy
during and after reconstruction guns
were often used to scare black voters
away at the polls
that history of armed voter intimidation
is not a distant memory
guns at the polls are a tinderbox near
an open flame
in manchester during the november 2020
election an armed man harassed people
holding signs for candidates in the
election electioneering area
outside three separate polling places
in charlotte north carolina an armed man
was arrested after a polling supervisor
asked him to leave a polling place on
election day and he returned
in lane county oregon armed individuals
approached voters as they were dropping
off their ballots
hb 1096 is a simple proactive attempt to
make our election safer for all of our
citizens
this bill amends our current voter
intimidation statute to prohibit open
carrying or display of a deadly weapon
within 100 feet of a polling place on
the days where federal state and or
municipal elections are taking place
what the bill does not do is eliminate
the right to self-defense
there are exceptions in the bill for
voters and election officials who are
legally carrying concealed weapons
there are also exceptions for law
enforcement officials and even pickup
truck owners with shotguns or rifles
secured in their gun racks
this bill is needed because under
current law state and local authorities
can't prevent people from bringing guns
into polling places
the supreme court of the united states
i'm sorry the supreme court of the
united states said it best
no right is more precious in a free
country than of having a voice in the
election of those who make the laws
under which we as good citizens must
live
other rights
even the most basic are illusory if the
right to vote is undermined
however the fundamental right to vote
without fear intimidation vital to our
democracy is endangered when we allow
deadly weapons to be displayed as an
implicit threat to others either inside
or outside our polling places
in the heller decision justice antonin
scalia wrote that while the second
amendment protects the right of law and
abiding responsible citizens to use
to use arms in the defense of hearth and
home he also wrote that nothing in this
opinion should be taken to cast doubt on
long-standing prohibitions on laws
forbidding the carrying of firearms in
sensitive places such as schools or
government buildings
several states including georgia have
gone on to interpret sensitive places to
include polling places
the bottom line is that hb 1096
doesn't force us to choose between
voting rights and second amendment
rights because it honors both
the right to self-defense is still
protected
absolutely nothing in this bill changes
the right of voters or election
officials to carry concealed weapons
into polling places for self-defense
purposes
but one thing would change weapons would
not be allowed to be displayed openly or
near polling places where they have the
very real potential to intimidate others
who are simply trying to exercise their
right to vote
i ask you to vote red to overturn the
committee recommendations so another
motion can be made and i ask for a
division vote
thank you
there's been a request for a roll call
before i get to the last speaker is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote
members take your seats
chair recognizes representative abbess
thank you mr speaker
thank you mr speaker i rise in support
of the committee's recommendation of
index speeding to legislate
just to clarify we hear we often hear uh
quotes from the supreme court and the
heller decision
just to click just so everyone
understands in that case there was no
discussion of new hampshire's article 2a
which is many legal scholars believe is
much more
protective of firearm rights than the
second amendment
there's a lot of things i said last time
we were here about an exception for a
pickup truck
and not not being able to uh open carry
on your private property this bill
hb 1096 contains the
same issues
if you live adjacent to a place where
there is it's a polling station you can
be standing on your front lawn however
because you are within 100 feet of that
polling place
you would be violating the law
this would apply if you're driving in
your vehicle in a community that you are
not familiar with but you happen to
drive by a polling place unknowingly
you would be violating the law
and i go back to that pickup truck
exception and well i do drive a pickup
truck so
i would benefit from that but i don't
see i i have no understanding why you're
excluding
an suv or vans or other vehicles from
that
and we hear a lot about intimidation of
voters and scaring people
threatening someone is a crime and
against the law and it always will be
and in new hampshire
we
prior legislators were responsible
enough to make an enhanced penalty that
if you threaten someone with a firearm
it's actually an enhanced penalty and
it's a felony so whether you're at a
voting station
a hospital
the grocery store
threatening someone
with a firearm is a crime already under
new hampshire law
therefore please join me and push the
green button and support the committee's
recommendation of endings being to
legislate thank you mr speaker
this is a roll call vote members take
your seats
so
the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpediting to legislator on
house bill 109 6.
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative penalakis for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that people should be able to
vote without the fear of gone guns
and i further know that guns are not
needed on school grounds
and i believe that people at the polls
should have the right to vote without
fear
would i now press the red button to vote
no on the itl so another motion
can be made
thank you
chair recognizes representative burke
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
if i know house bill 1096 would prohibit
open carrying a firearm within a hundred
feet of a polling place or the
electioneering areas
mr speaker
if i know the committee is unaware of
any problems with people carrying
firearms while voting
and it has been legal in new hampshire
for hundreds of years
and lastly mr speaker
if i know there are many unattended
consequences to house bill 1096 if
passed would i now press the green
button to itl house bill 1096. thank you
mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
report of any speeding to legislator in
house bill 1096 this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
okay
representative bouchard
thumbs up for thumbs down
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
under 90 voting a 153 voting a the
committee report is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk
mr speaker the committee on enrolled
bills is examined and found correctly
enrolled the following entitled bills
senate bill 307 house bill 435 and house
bill 95
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety delicious
referred house bill
and 1105 relative to earned time credits
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
senator terry roy for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same we've been
able to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolve
that it's inexpedient to legislate
representative david muse for the
minority of the committee
are you the question is on the uh
majority report of interim study on
house bill 1105 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have a committee reporters
adopted
majority of committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 1108 and act
relative to the prescribed manner of
posting land having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is in expedient
to legislative john burt from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
representative casey conley from the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative conley
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
hb 1108 has become known in our
committee as the purple paint bill
it would give property owners
flexibility in how they post their
property
posting for those who don't know is a
process where you prohibit access or
limit access to certain activities on
your private land
current law makes very clear how
property should be posted
typically the owner must
use very specific signs these signs cost
money anywhere from a dollar to ten
dollars per sign
they must be placed within 100 yards of
each other
and they must be kept in good order so
this basically means the property owner
must walk their parcel
uh every year or so ensuring that it's
posted
to the letter of the law
for a very large parcel the cost of
buying these signs and replacing these
signs can add up
our committee heard testimony that it is
not easy to traverse your property line
every year or two we learn that using
nails to post these signs can damage the
tree
and some elderly property owners are
physically unable to walk their property
to meet this law
hb 1108 would give these property owners
the ability to mark their land with
purple blazes on trees
the method is used in 16 states and i
have full confidence that new hampshire
residents can quickly figure out what a
purple blaze means
the property owners who came before our
committee
asked for choice in how they post their
property they consider this a question
of property rights which is something
our state has long considered sacrosanct
i ask that you oppose the itl so a more
appropriate motion can be made thank you
we are on the final speaker
representative burt has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently second in this will
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
chair recognizes representative byrd
thank you
mr speaker
we heard from the new hampshire division
of forest and lands
mr speaker in their letter that they
gave us in opposition of this bill
quote
there are well-established time-tested
standards for boundary marking used by
licensed surveyors in foresters
that are more effective than those
proposed in this bill
that is from the new hampshire division
of forest and lands
mr speaker
fish and game also spoke new hampshire
fish and game also spoke in front of the
committee
and they said maine passed this
they said more people are hunting on
purple painted
property in maine than on any other
properties
they said it's very confusing
people don't understand it
and
the main fishing game wish they could
get rid of the law
lastly mr speaker
we also heard
that new hampshire is unique
we have what is called
common land rule
in some states you don't go on people's
properties without getting permission
new hampshire is unique
we can go on anybody's property
unless it's posted
so up in the
woods fields mountains you know we can
just walk out into them
that is what you know is beautiful about
new hampshire
and mr speaker i've also heard
that
the national forest or the national
parks
has some
trails that use purple paint
how confusing is that going to be
and lastly well i said lastly once
before but i'll say it again lastly
i understand that people can
and will
just drive down the road and spray paint
a tree purple and then it becomes posted
at that point even if the landowner does
not want it so i hope you will vote to
support the itl thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
report of any explaining to legislate on
house bill 1108
this is a roll call vote members will be
in their seats
the chair recognizes representative reid
for parliamentary inquiry
go ahead
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the new
hampshire constitution makes clear that
property rights private property rights
are sacrosanct in our state
and if i know that laws regulating the
exact way landowners must post their
land lest they be forced to allow anyone
in the onto their private property
restricts those property rights and if i
know that 1108 would not change any
trespass laws but merely give landowners
the same choice they have in 26 other
states with the use of paint which is
more durable easier physically easier to
use and cheaper states like texas
alabama florida
and finally i know that this is so
commonly used that major paint brands
like krylon and rust-oleum actually
create a no trespass purple color for
this exact purpose then mr speaker would
i now press the red button
okay
the chair recognizes representative burt
for parliamentary and gray
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know the committee heard
testimony from the new hampshire fish
and game department that their peers in
maine a state that allows purple paint
post and say purple paint hosting is
utterly chaos
and often there are more people hunting
on purple painted properties and the
unposted properties
mr speaker if i know the committee also
heard from the new hampshire division of
forest and lands that the current post
and requirements which the landowner's
name and contact information on the
signs is a good practice for a number of
reasons i.e retrieving game animals
notifying landowners of
fire suppressor suppression activities
and lastly mr speaker
if i know the committee also heard from
the new hampshire
timber
land owners association
a land organization
whose members own and manage over one
million acres of land also opposes house
bill 1108
for many reasons would i now press the
green button
to itl this purple bill thank you mr
speaker the motion before is the
majority report of inexperience to
legislate on house bill 1108 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
me
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
239 voting yay 102 voting a the
committee reports adopted
committee on criminal justice public
safety to which was referred house bill
and act relative to the circumstances
constituting criminal threatening
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senator
terry roy for the committee
the chair recognizes representative
espedia to speak against the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
in may of 2021 a white nationalist group
named nsc 131 came to nashua and they
painted keep new hampshire white
and also swastikas in a neighborhood
that is a majority minority
neighborhood on our public rail trail
traversed by so many constituents
following this i spoke out as well as
you know as we all should be against
this hate and i hope anyone would speak
out against it and they responded
that any uh by quote saying that anyone
with the name manny espithia state rep
or not has no moral right to throw shade
at any true white nationalist new
hampshire right
they said you have no right to be here
you're an occupier here and the days of
these types trampling on new england are
coming to an end
for some of y'all who have gone through
the experience of being threatened you
know that the fear you you know that
fear that you get that runs down your
spine and what got me through was the
support from so many of you in this room
on both sides of the aisle and i
appreciate everyone who was who was
there and reached out
we need to crack down on hate speech and
neo-nazis in our state and that's why i
filed this bill this spill adds the
intent to coerce or terrorize the people
of one age sex
gender identity sexual orientation race
creed color marital status familial
status mental or physical disability
religion or national origin to the
criminal threatening statute
this bill aims to address anti-semitic
and racist threatening acts like these
on public property in new hampshire
communities and allow law enforcement to
intervene and prosecute those
responsible
hate speech and threatening in new
hampshire is not an isolated incident as
we've seen all across the state
similar acts have popped up around
communities in new hampshire for years
from posters with terrorizing images
symbols and words of graffiti with
threatening phrases on our sidewalks
acts of discrimination and hate are
wrong for new hampshire
something we all value
as in new hampshire is that we're a
welcoming place to people of all
backgrounds
race religion sex gender and creed our
communities are stronger and safer when
we address when we address acts of
terrorism discrimination and threatening
head-on it is time for our state to take
a stand so i ask you all to please
overturn the itl and support another
motion thank you
chair recognizes representative abbas
speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the committee's
recommendation of index being to
legislate
although i share many of the same
concerns as my
my friend from nashua
and i think we all agree that
what occurred was not was not okay and
it's not welcomed in the state
but i support the motion of inexpensive
legislators the criminal threatening
rsa that's on the law today
applies to any person
with anyone who's coerced or terrorized
any person
by adding
religion
race
any of these other categories any any
person covers all of that already
everything that if this law were to
apply to that instant
that conduct would have already fallen
under the existing law today
for that reason
i ask you to support me and push the
green button support the committee's
recommendation of indexing to legislate
thank you mr speaker does the member
yield to questions
member does not yield
motion before us
is the ito motion on hb1117
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
take their seats
clear
the motion before us is the committee
report of linux bidding to legislate on
house bill 1117.
this is going to be a division vote
chair recognizes representative harriet
gothright for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know persons placing graffiti on
public property for the purpose to
coerce
or to terrorize
and if i know persons threatened to
commit any crime against the property of
another
for the purpose
of terrorizing
i would push the red button so that
another motion could be made
the chair recognizes representative
rhodes for a parliamentary inquiry
representative roy
sounds close
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that the current statute
currently says all people
and i know that the groups listed in
this statute proposed statute include
all people
and lastly mr speaker if i knew
that by
listing specific groups you always leave
someone out and you could not get
broader than all people would i not
support the committee position
of any expedient to legislate and push
the green button thank you
motion before us is the committee report
of interest meeting to legislator on
house bill 1117.
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay to the vote
under an 87 voting yeah 154 voting made
a committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 1127.
an act relative to posthumous
exonerations and annulments having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative john bourdinet for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator david muse from the
minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative muse to speak
against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
it's always interesting to see what
happens
when a witch hunt meets moral integrity
unfortunately moral integrity doesn't
always win and neither does justice
will it uphouse and goody cole are two
prime examples from our own new
hampshire history
cole was the victim of an actual witch
hunt
she was convicted flogged and imprisoned
for witchcraft over 200 years ago
uphouse was the victim of another kind
of witch hunt
in the 1950s he was sentenced to a year
in jail for refusing to turn over a list
of guests and staff
of the world fellowship organization
to an overzealous new hampshire attorney
general who wanted to comb through those
lists looking for communists and
connections to subversive organizations
with the passage of time it has become
increasingly apparent that a great
injustice was done to both
hb 1127 is an opportunity for moral
integrity to finally triumph
it would not only set the record
straight for these two individuals
it would also set the record straight
when it comes to our history
the prime sponsor of this bill
always took the words of martin luther
king to heart
the ark of the moral universe is long
but it bends towards justice
while we can't go back in time
and erase injustice through this bill
we would have the power both moral and
statutory to set the record straight
to acknowledge our past mistakes and to
carve out a place in our law that lets
future legislators set the record
straight for others in similar
circumstances
there are some who argue that this is a
privilege that is better conferred by
the governor
but what we're talking about
in these cases aren't pardons for
individuals who are still living
what we're talking about is a way for
the legislature to set the record
straight in those very rare instances
when a person who is no longer with us
has suffered an incredible injustice at
the hands of the state
this
word for word
is ex
this bill is word for word
exactly the same bill as another bill
that we passed on consent in 2020 that
died in the other body because of covet
i urge you to vote red to reverse the
committee recommendation so another
motion may be made thank
the you record recognizes representative
bourdinet for speaking for the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
the committee
did agree that there was good intent for
this bill and we agreed on the idea that
the bill
had for it but
during testimony and hearing we found
out that there are some technical
legalities that
the bill did not address properly and we
need to address those properly for
example
the goody was convicted by the
commonwealth of massachusetts
well
if i understand
law the state of new hampshire
cannot involve
a
conviction of another state
so
in this case
i would prefer that we
passed the
committee's
recommendation of interim study so that
we can
straighten things out and make it
correct thank you
the motion before us is the majority
report of interim study on house bill
1127.
are you ready for the question
all those
division has been requested members will
take their seats
again i would ask that if you want a
division or a roll call let me know
before the final speaker so we can move
this along
the motion before us is the majority
report of interim study on house bill
1127. this is going to be a division
vote the chair recognizes representative
conley for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know this bill
was a matter of deep
personal interest for our
former democratic leader
and if i know this bill gives our state
a tool
to address historic injustices like that
of someone convicted of witchcraft
would i then press the red button to
oppose this motion so another one could
be made thank you
chair recognizes representative abbess
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that we heard testimony that
the legislator does not have the
authority to grant an annulment never
mind an annulment to a specific person
should i go ahead and push the
green button and support the committee's
recommendation of interim study thank
you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
report of interim study in house bill
1127. this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed to press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
so
[Music]
representative nordgrid
you can't push it now i need a thumbs up
or a thumbs down
and while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
state of the vote
251 voting 88 voting a committee report
is adopted
like to give
a thank you to representative gamalo for
providing the flowers in the rostrum
this afternoon
for something like that you can clap
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred house bill
1178. enact
an act prohibiting the state from
enforcing any federal statute regulation
or presidential executive order that
restricts or regulates the right of the
people to keep and bear arms having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
president of john burt for the committee
for what reason does the member rise
make state your motion
my motion is the table hb 1266
1178 sorry
the motion the motion before us is the
table house bill 1178
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently second it is officially
second second in members will take your
seats
house will be in order
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on house bill 1178
this is going to be a roll call vote the
chair recognizes representative bradley
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that keeping firearms and
other deadly weapons out of the hands of
criminals and criminal gangs
is one of the most important duties of
both our state and federal governments
and if i know that this bill
makes the tough job
of federal and state law enforcement
officials even tougher
then i would then would i press the
green button
to table
the house recognizes
representative burt for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
if i know
what is going on over in the ukraine
and mr speaker if i know
that both democrat and republican
attorney generals have opined
that new hampshire law enforcement
should not
be should not been force in any federal
laws
mr speaker and lastly if i know
that i would vote
red on this motion thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1178 this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
kaplan
representative sawfiquidus
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the vote
153 voting ye 187 voting a the motion to
table fails
the question is now on the amendment
zero four seven nine h printed in house
record 10 a page 17.
are you ready for the question on the
[Music]
questions
the question is on the amendment
i if you're in favor say aye
if you're opposed say nay
the amendment passes the question now is
on
the ought to pass as amended
chair recognizes representative muse
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
as amended
hb 1178 is bad public policy that would
prohibit state local and county police
from enforcing and cooperating with the
enforcement of any u.s firearms law
federal regulation or presidential
executive order that we also don't have
on the books here in new hampshire
what often gets lost in this debate is
that there are relatively few federal
gun laws on the books anyway
the ones that we do have on the books
are similar to the laws that we have in
new hampshire that make it illegal to
straw purchase a firearm on behalf of
another person or to provide a gun to
someone who is banned from having one
the problem is that existing state and
federal laws alone have not been enough
to stop criminals specializing in
trafficking guns across state lines to
other criminals and criminal gangs
that's where the recent efforts of the
biden administration come in
in 2021 the president announced the
formation of strike forces intended to
sharply curtail significant firearms
trafficking corridors that have diverted
guns to five major urban areas
also announced were programs to work
with states to gather data on firearms
traffic trafficking for policy makers as
well as rules that have yet to be
finalized to stop the proliferation of
ghost guns
ghost guns for those of you who may not
be familiar with them are unmarked guns
without serial numbers that are sold as
components in kit form
these kits are easy to assemble often
they come 80 percent pre-assembled and
are currently exempt from background
checks
making them hugely attractive to
criminals
while hb 1178 may have the stated
purpose of protecting second amendment
rights
what it would also do is undermine
cooperation between state and federal
law enforcement in a very critical area
the result is easy to predict
more guns winding up in the hands of
more dangerous criminals
hb 1178 is not about protecting gun
rights our state and federal
constitutions already do a pretty good
job of that
what hb 1178 about is about is scoring
political points by driving a divisive
and unnecessary wedge between the state
and federal government when it comes to
keeping guns out of the hands of
criminals
it also has the very real potential of
greatly increasing the flow of illegal
firearms including ghost guns into and
out of our state
the bottom line is hb 1178 does not make
new hampshire any safer for our
residents our law enforcement personnel
or our visitors
please press the red button so another
motion may be made
thank you
do you recognize his representative lynn
to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
we are fortunate to live in a state that
strongly supports the right to keep and
bear arms
unfortunately at the federal level under
the current administration that is not
the case
indeed based upon its actions to date
it seems clear that the present
administration in washington
regards the second amendment as a pesky
nuisance
that it would repeal in a heartbeat if
it had the power to do so
but since it doesn't have that power
it has set about a course of legislative
and regulatory proposals the aim of
which is to effectively emasculate the
second amendment through the strategy of
death by a thousand cuts
hb seven eleven seventy eight is
designed to ensure
that new hampshire never becomes
complicit in that strategy
the provisions of the bill are simple
and straightforward
section one of the bill says that no
personnel
or financial resources of this state or
its political subdivisions
shall be used to enforce administer
or cooperate with the federal government
in the enforcement of any federal law
regulation or executive order regarding
the regulation of firearms ammunition
firearms components etc
that is inconsistent with new hampshire
law regarding the same subject matters
because
as in most states new hampshire law
enforcement has a long history of
cooperating with federal authorities in
many areas of mutual interest
section two of the bill
makes it clear that the prohibitions in
section one
do not apply when federal authorities
are investigating someone as to whom
there is reasonable suspicion to believe
he or she he or she has committed a
violation of state law or a violation of
a federal law not covered by section one
section two also allows state
authorities to provide their federal
counterparts with publicly available
information criminal history information
or information needed to fulfill new
hampshire's responsibilities under the
national crime prevention and privacy
contract
under the leadership of the chair and
the prime sponsor the representative
from goffstown of the criminal justice
committee that that committee worked
very hard to achieve consensus on this
legislation among various stakeholders
it includes provisions for example
suggested by the new hampshire attorney
general
and by the nra
gunner and gun owners of america all of
which all of whom have reviewed the bill
the bill's language and are on board
with it i respectfully ask that you
support this bill by by pressing the
green button
thank you and mr speaker i would request
a roll call vote on this
a roll call a roll call has been
requested that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded members will
take their seats this will be a roll
call vote
oh for me i'm sorry
yeah
yes
mr speaker i have a question for you
have the rules of decorum in this body
changed it was my understanding that we
are never to assume motives of other
people and the previous speaker
very definitely did
ascribe to the president of the united
states and many others motives that may
or may not be accurate
uh you are correct representative and
unfortunately it was said before i got a
chance to say anything because i didn't
know it was going to be said so
uh the rest of his the rest of his
testimony was
without malice i believe
the question before us is the ought to
pass with amendment motion on 1178
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
bradley for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that keeping firearms and
other deadly materials out of the hands
of criminals and criminal gangs is one
of the most
important duties of both our state and
federal governments
and if i know that the bill makes this
tough
on federal and state law enforcement
and it makes it even tougher
then would i press the red button so
another motion can be made
chair recognized represented by
parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
if i know house bill 1178 would prohibit
the state from enforcing any federal
statute regulations
or presidential executive orders that
restrict or regulate the right of the
people to keep and bear arms
mr speaker if i know over the years
on many topics both
democrat and republican attorney
generals have opined that new hampshire
law enforcement should not
should not been forcing federal laws
and lastly mr speaker if i know this is
a simple concept state and local police
are hired
trained and compensated
with the state and local tax dollars
it makes no sense to divert those scant
resources to
enforce federal laws that if they were
they are to be enforced should properly
be enforced by federal law enforcement
would i now press that very bright green
button
and pass this common sense second
amendment bill thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the committee
report of what passes amended on house
bill 1178 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you post you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend to the
state of the vote
190 voting day 147 voting a the
committee report is adopted
what reason does it memorize mr speaker
i would like to have the remarks of the
previous speakers put in the permanent
journal
the debate
uh
the request is to have the remarks the
re from the debate
printed in the permanent journal
without objection
uh
the question before the house it should
the remarks
that i would ask for a division vote
please
could i ask for a division
division vote has been requested members
will take their seats
this will be on printing the remarks
from the previous debate in the
permanent journal
so
good
the motion before us is the print the
remarks
in the permanent journal from the past
debate
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if he opposed you or press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative herbert
yes or no please
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will tend
to stay to the vote
under 97 voting 841 voting a the remarks
will be printed from the previous debate
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred 1266.
house will come to order
and act relative to restrictions on
enforcement of federal immigration laws
have been considered the same report the
same with the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative terry
roy the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and be an unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate president of
linda harriet garth wright for the
minority of the committee
the amendment is 0914h
printed in house record
a
on page 37
the question is on the amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor of the amendment
say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it an amendment is adopted
chair recognizes representative harriet
garth right to speak against the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
the
amendment as well as the underlying bill
is a far reach for an issue that's not
there
at the moment the fair and impartial
police policy adopted by various
departments state that they will
cooperate with immigration and customs
enforcement ice if there has been a
valid warrant
therefore the amendment creates another
issue around valid warrants verse
requests
the bill is confusing vague and
oppressive to many
this bill requires municipalities to
violate the 4th and 14th amendments
and will
subject these entities to liability for
those violations
remember that a person's presence in the
united states in violation of
immigration laws standing alone is not a
crime
immigration violations are mostly civil
not criminal in nature
ice detainers are issued by ice agents
themselves without any authorization or
oversight by a judge
or other neutral decision makers
ice detainers are not warrants but a
mayor request
it is not a crime for an undocumented
person to remain in the united states
the bill contributes to the rise in hate
and injustice perpetuated by national
anti-immigration
immigrant organizations
this bill undermines community trust in
law enforcement and will make new
hampshire less safe perhaps may be less
likely
to report a crime or even testify as a
witness to a crime
even for domestic violence
it may make the job of law
enforcement harder people afraid to talk
and afraid of being deported after
assisting law enforcement
this bill makes it illegal for a state
or local agency to exercise its
discretion
threatening local control again the bill
expects cities and towns to expend
resources to enforce federal immigration
laws
without reimbursement from the state or
federal government
the state
should not be about controlling the
decisions of cities or towns
we love our motto live free or die and
that's what most immigrants are
attempting to do
[Music]
we're going to take up the final speaker
in a second first of all we've had a
request for a roll call is that by
representative conley is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded members will
take their seats this will be a roll
call vote chair recognizes
representative abbas
thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the committee's
recommendation of ought to pass as
amended of house bill 1266.
for some points of clarification
h.b 1266 does not mandate that the
police or local law enforcement
officials enforce federal laws
it also does not mandate or force or
require law enforcement to
comply with cooperate with any detainer
requests by the federal government
it allows police to use their discretion
when a person is already in custody
someone who's been arrested
and charged with the crime in that
situation
it leaves the discretion to that law
enforcement agency whether they wish to
cooperate with a detainer request
during the public hearing we heard
a lot of compelling testimony talking
about
discretion discretion and to allow the
police to have discretion
the amendment that was just adopted did
exactly that it gave the law enforcement
the discretion to make a sound decision
on a case-by-case basis
some communities
in new hampshire have adopted local
ordinances or policies where
no matter no matter what the
circumstances
they the law enforcement body is not
permitted to actually cooperate with or
honor
any type of detainer request by the
federal government
and to put that in perspective think of
a hypothetical situation you can have a
person
who is arrested for a
misdemeanor under state law
and upon an investigation while the
person's already in custody can be
literally
wanted by the federal government for
acts of terrorism however because of the
policy adopted by some communities
well that person would be released
despite the
threat to public safety they may
pose
so please join me
in pushing that green button supporting
the committee's recommendation of ought
to pass as amended thank you mr speaker
does the member yield to questions
remember does not yield
the motion before us is the ought to
pass as amended on house bill 1166 this
is a roll call vote members will be in
their seats chair recognizes
representative conley for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know this bill puts local and state
police in new hampshire in the position
of enforcing federal immigration laws
and if i know this bill contains no
penalty whatsoever
for violating it and therefore is
completely symbolic
if i agree with my colleague from
goffstown that federal authorities
should enforce federal laws and state
police
should enforce state laws would i then
press the red button to defeat this
motion thank you
[Music]
geo recognizes representative roy for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this law
would not cause the enforcement of any
law state federal or otherwise and if i
further know that all that this would do
is that during the booking process if a
detainer popped up the police would have
the option to contact ice and not be
forbidden would i then agree with the
committee and press the green button for
ought to pass as amended thank you
the motion before us has ought to pass
as amended
on house bill 1166 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
grain button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
hmm
while members president an opportunity
to vote household 10 to state of the
vote
172 voting yeah 162 voting aid a
committee report is adopted
all members will stay in their seats
we've got a division with only pis
right coming up
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 1296-fn
an act relative to money coin or
currency which may be forfeited in
connection with a drug offense consider
the same report the same with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment president of john
hunt for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
david muse for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is zero eight
four
printed in house record 10 a pages 40-46
are you ready for the question on the
amendment are you all you all in favor
say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
okay this is not going to be a division
are you the motion before us is the
committee report about to pass as
amended on house bill 12-1296
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it committed report is
adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
deferred house bill 1306 fn act relative
to personal possession of marijuana
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
representative terry roy from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
able to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative linden harriet garth
wright for the minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
thank you mr speaker i'd like to make a
motion to table hb 1306
that is a proper motion the motion
before us
is to table house bill 1306
mr speaker i request a division
a division has been requested
members will take their seats
[Music]
so
the motion before us is to table house
bill 1306
this is a division vote chair recognizes
representative branch just for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill is considered
the back-up marijuana reform bill
and if i know that all this bill does is
further decriminalize marijuana by
reducing the fines for personal
possession slightly increasing the
possession limit from three quarters of
an ounce to an ounce and completely
removes criminal penalties for personal
possession
and finally if i know that this house
has passed many marijuana bills this
session and we are waiting to see what
the other body will do with them would i
now press the green button to table this
bill to await what the other body will
do with our other marijuana bills thank
you
recognizes right
chair i recognize the representative
abyss for a parliamentary inquiry
wave off
the motion before us is the
laying on the table of house bill 1306
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
president an opportunity to vote house
will attend the state of the vote
309 voting a 28 voting a
house bill 1306 is laid on the table
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 1348 fn and act
relative to the legalization of a
certain amount of cannabis having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study senator terry
roy from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
senator david meals from the minority of
the committee
for what reason does a member rise thank
you mr speaker i wish to make a motion
to table hb 1348
motion is in order
the motion before us is to table
house bill 1348
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in the 1348 is laid on
the table
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 1361 fn enact
establishing a penalty for any person
who transports a controlled drug into
new hampshire with the intent to
distribute and consider the same report
the same with the following amendment
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment instead of terry
roy for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate senate
amanda bolden for the minority of the
committee the amendment is zero zero
eight seven h printed in house record
10a page 53. are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the chair recognizes
representative abramson to speak against
the committee report
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker i rise in
opposition
to the ought to pass as amended motion
on house bill 1361 fn
every time congress has voted to step up
the war on drugs since lbj announced it
on national television in 1969 crime has
gone up
not down
drug use has tripled addiction rates
have soared and now over 70 thousand
americans die from illegal narcotics
because they have been made felonized
the number was around 1 000 before the
social engineering experiment was
launched 55 years ago
house bill 1361 fn would make it a class
a felony with a mandatory minimum of
five years in prison to merely have two
ounces
of cannabis in your car for the crime of
addiction or even having
marijuana in your possession with an
expired
mm
marijuana medical marijuana id card or
one from out of state
reckless vehicular homicide is a class b
felony as is rape those are class b
felonies
this bill as introduced was a class a
felony do we use the prison industry and
for servitude as the magical elixir for
to eating addiction spending addiction
gambling addiction
or alcohol addiction
this is an insidious form of socialism
and social engineering that has caged
and chained up millions of young poor
and brown americans
89 years ago
nine delegates met in the next room
in the senate chambers to ratify the
21st amendment to admit the utter
failure of alcohol prohibition a social
engineering experiment that left
thousands of americans dead from mob
wars and illegal liquor
alcohol prohibition had turned
law-abiding patriots into nighttime
scoff laws and patrons of speakeasies
like drug and gun prohibition it had
turned desperate people into junkies
homeless addicts pariahs and left
countless children in broken and
impoverished homes
god gave us 10 laws and
excuse me
and warned us not to replace those with
our own ephemeral monstrosities
politicians
for the last century have ignored these
warnings and killed an estimated 2
million americans and by some estimates
as many as 3 million with drug
prohibition a dozen other western
countries have ended the scourge and
switched to harm reduction the old
american approach that worked oregon
voters
two years ago voted overwhelmingly
to pass drug decriminalization by a
17-point margin
and crime in their state has declined
today
57 percent of americans support drug
decrement i ask you to press the red
button
chair i recognize the representative
connolly to speak against the community
report
thank you mr speaker this bill would
make it a felony as we just heard to
transport drugs across state lines for
the purpose of selling them
if you're thinking isn't this already a
crime you'd be right it is already a
class a felony in new hampshire
does a felony to possess drugs with
intent to sell in our state
regardless of how the drugs got here
and this bill would be very hard to
enforce how do you prove that somebody
brought the drugs over a state line
this bill would create a new mandatory
minimum at a time when this house under
democratic and republican majorities
have voted to eliminate mandatory
minimums in drug sentencing
it would make the vehicle used for the
crime
stipulated in this bill subject to
forfeiture
yet hb 1296 which this house just passed
on a voice vote
exempted certain vehicles from
forfeiture so how these two bills get
squared on this issue i really have no
idea
selling drugs is clearly an awful crime
drug dealers can and should be punished
and they are under existing law
depending on the circumstance this act
can bring a mandatory life sentence
as a society we've seen the negative
effects associated with the war on drugs
we know that passing new laws with
longer sentences does nothing to deter
crime particularly drug crimes
they have contributed to larger prison
sentence prison populations in new
hampshire and across the country and yet
here in new hampshire the cost of
incarcerating someone in state prison is
44 000 a year
existing law gives prosecutors plenty
of flexibility to arrest prosecute and
punish the bad guys
we don't need any laws that duplicate
what's already on the books
i ask you defeat this motion by pressing
the red button so another could be made
thank you
a division vote has been requested
we're down to the last speaker
so members take their seats
chair recognizes representative roy
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker this bill is different than
the law currently on the books first of
all with regard to what the first
speaker said regarding cannabis
it was absolutely incorrect this law
exempts cannabis from being one of the
laws that could trigger this
second of all i am in agreement with the
second speaker that we are trying to
roll back the sentences and the rule on
drugs as it applies to individual users
who are victims who are addicts who need
help
but at the same time as we roll back
those
we have to address the the problem of
these drugs coming into our state we
wouldn't have as many addicts if we
didn't have as much drugs so the drugs
aren't being made in new hampshire
they're being brought into new hampshire
now the previous speaker asked how would
we know where they came from well it's
not difficult when a vehicle gets pulled
over crossing the state line and there's
drugs worthy inside of the level of
distribution to know where it came from
it came across the state line
so at the same time as we address the
scourge of addiction
and we have to do something to stop the
drugs coming in and this is a very very
strong deterrent if you know that
there's a chance that you're going to
get pulled over coming to the state of
new hampshire to distribute your poison
to our children that you would do five
years mandatory in jail you're going to
think twice about it and you're going to
think twice about risking your property
and your freedom
i think that's a small price to pay in
exchange for the lives of our children
that we are losing every day
the war on drugs itself
is is the way it's going it's losing
so let's look at it differently let's
treat the people who are using the drugs
give them the treatment they need and
appropriately punish the people who are
bringing the poison across the borders
to this state they are not originating
in new hampshire i would ask you to
support the committee's decision and
vote ought to pass as amended on this
bill thank you very much
this is a division vote
pis have been waived off so we're going
to go into the vote
the motion before us
is ought to pass as amended on house
bill
1361 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you opposed to press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
uh
if all members president an opportunity
to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
153 voting yeah 187 voting a
the motion fails
mr speaker i'd like to make a motion
state your motion delay
hb 1361 on the table
representative conley moves that hb one
three i misspoke
mr chairman
thank you mr clerk i misspoke
in my first time making such a motion
and i would move itl please forgive the
error
the motion before us
is the minority port of inexperience to
legislate on health bill 1361
a division has been requested members
will
take their seats
the motion
is in expedient to legislate on house
bill 1361
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you approach you
can't do it
we're we're already in the voting mode
right now
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
represent perez
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
207 voting yay 131 voting nay
the minority port of inexpensive
legislators adopted
what's up
the committee on criminal justice and
public safety which was referred house
bill 1400 and act prohibiting law
enforcement from using the scent of
marijuana as probable cause for a search
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative terry roy for
the committee
mr mr speaker
for reason does a member rise
i rise to make a motion a table hb 1400
i was
i'm sorry what
table this one
i i moved the table hb 1400. okay
representative abbas moves to table
1400.
division this will be a division vote
members take receipts
the question before the house is whether
to lay house bill 1400 on the table
representative conley is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that
judges in our state have already ruled
that the scent of cannabis alone
does not give probable cause for a
search
and if i know that this very simple bill
puts that standard into law
mr speaker if i know it is the job of
the legislature not judges to make laws
would i press the red button to defeat
tabling so we can debate this bill and
hopefully overturn the other motion
thanks
representative abbas is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that hp
1400 attempts to codify a
holding from the new hampshire supreme
court
without the rest of the context of the
case to actually give the holding
context in the law
and mr speaker if i know that this could
cause confusion in what is otherwise a
well-settled area of law would i go
ahead and push that green button support
the motion and table thank you mr
speaker
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1400 on the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
representative
suffocatus have all members president
had an opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
168 in the affirmative 157 and the
negative house bill 1400 is laid on the
table
this one
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred house bill 1414 an
act requiring the state police to submit
an annual report on traffic violations
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that it has been expedient to
legislate representative terry roy for
the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative casey conley for the
minority of the committee the questions
on the majority committee report of an
ex of in expediences
legislate are ready for the question all
those in favor say aye all those opposed
nay
[Music]
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred house bill 1476 fn
an act relative to persons arrested
while out on bail having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
representative casey conley for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it
has been expedient to legislate
representative ray newman for the
minority of the committee
the questions on the committee amendment
zero eight nine five h printed on house
record 10 a on page 65. are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
for reason doesn't remember rise
for a motion mr speaker
state emotion i move uh house bill 1476
to be placed on the table
alrighty who requested a roll call
representative barry requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
please take your seats
yeah
only on one side
all right the house will come to order
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1476 on the table
representative bolton is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i believe that this bill
nearly eliminates bail reform
and is strongly opposed by people across
the political spectrum
and if i know that there's a bill coming
over from the other body which is
preferable to this bill and if i know
that we have another
177 bills to get through in the next
couple days would i now push the green
button to lay this bill upon the table
representative barry is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
you mr speaker mr speaker if i know that
this bill is the culmination of a
bipartisan effort over the last six
months to address bail reform and mr
speaker if i know that this bill does in
fact leave the core principles of
existing bail reform in law and mr
speaker if i know that this bill at a
minimum deserves a debate so that we may
be heard would i now press the red
button to oppose the tabling
motion the question is whether to lay
house bill 1476 on the table if you're
in favor you'll be pressing the green
button if you're opposed you'll be
pressing the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
do
there
representative testerman
representative chase
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
161 having voted in the affirmative 168
in the negative the motion fails
the question that was on the majority
committee report about to pass with
amendment the member from sandown
representative true was recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker house bill
1476 says that any person who's out on
bail and arrested for the third time
for a class b misdemeanor
shall be held in jail for no more than
36 hours pending a hearing for a judge
well
let's say held no more than three or
four days because no more than 36 hours
not including any holidays
or weekends
i ask you mr speaker
what type of person do you think would
be possibly be charged with a class b
demeanor
three or four times in a row before
they're even getting
been taken before a judge
i suggest that they could possibly be a
person with drug problems
or they could be a homeless person
or they could be a person with serious
mental health issues
i suggest that these people
this bill will affect
those among us
who have the very least
please note that anyone found guilty of
a class b misdemeanor will only be
subject to a mis for fine
no jail time is associated at all with a
class b misdemeanor
mr speaker
where is the justice
in throwing a person in jail for two or
three or four days
when if they were eventually found
guilty the judge simply says
guilty with a hundred dollar fine
no jail time
does that make any sense to you
throwing a person with mental health or
addiction issues in jail
is not therapy
house bill 1476 creates an unfunded
mandate
by adding approximately 110 to 130 a day
for incarceration costs
per day
per person and that cost is forced on
the cities and counties as an unfunded
mandate
house bill 1476 violates the due process
rights of the accused
and does away
with
innocent until proven guilty
in closing
please allow me to quote from one of our
country's greatest disco bands
of all time
the barbie full of four
i fought the law and the lot won
please vote against this motion of otpa
so that the law in american jailor
students will win
please press the red button thank you mr
speaker
the member from manchester
representative bolden is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i've been quiet on this bill up until
now and that's because i'm in an awkward
position as chairman of the manchester
delegation and the city of manchester
supports this bill
however when i put on this name tag and
enter this chamber i don't represent the
city or its departments i represent the
residents of my district
and that and for that reason i rise to
speak against the committee report on hb
because i know the people of manchester
support bail reform
this bill purports to fix what is
characterized as a catch and release
system
supporters of this legislation claim
that dangerous individuals are being
released on bail where they then
continue to victimize people
if that were true how is it that crime
rates in nearly every category have
decreased since bail reform was passed
in 2018
in fact the overall crime rate is down
14 percent
the reality is that under bail reform
offenders who are dangerous are already
held in jail without bail
regardless of the crime they've
committed it's called preventive
detention it exists under current law
and it is implemented on a regular basis
in spite of the overall success that
bail reform has delivered this
legislation would have us move backward
to an era of higher crime and mass
incarceration
it brings back income-based
discrimination
it brings back
holding individuals in a jail cell
merely because they can't afford to buy
their freedom
it brings back a system where a wealthy
criminal goes home and a poor man stays
in jail that's not justice that's an
injustice
if this bill becomes law individuals who
are arrested while out on bail even for
a simple misdemeanor such as trespassing
must be held in jail for up to 36 hours
not including weekends or holidays until
they can see a judge
so if they're arrested on a friday
evening they could sit in jail until
wednesday
this bill also binds the hands of the
judge by removing personal recognizance
as a bail option
this means the judge must order cash
bail
and what if the defendant can't afford
it well they sit in jail probably for
months
just like people did before bail reform
was passed in 2018
therefore in effect hb 1476 guts bail
reform
this bill is going to harm homeless
people
it is going to harm people with mental
illnesses
it is going to harm people suffering
from addiction
and it is going to affect minorities
disproportionately
data from the fbi shows that black
people in new hampshire are more than
three and a quarter times more likely to
be arrested than white people
in fact local leaders of black lives
matter published an op-ed in the union
leader this week opposing this bill and
i quote
as we work to achieve a national
reckoning around systemic racism it is
unconscionable that legislators would
expand
the already disproportionate
incarceration of black people in new
hampshire we urge our lawmakers to
oppose hb 1476.
supporters of this legislation also
claim that people suffering from
substance misuse disorder can get
treatment in jail while they wait for
their trial while that just isn't true
individuals held pre-trial are not
eligible for treatment services
the list of organizations that are
fervently opposed to this bill is long
and includes rights and democracy
american friends service committee
the new hampshire council of churches
granite state organizing project
the new hampshire youth movement
the new hampshire high school democrats
black lives matter manchester
black lives matter seacoast
the new hampshire aclu
as well as various conservative groups
such as americans for our prosperity the
new hampshire liberty alliance
and the house republican alliance
these organizations certainly don't
agree very often but they all agree that
we need to kill this bill
why does this bill draw the ire of such
a bipartisan and diverse coalition of
organizations and activists
it's because they all see it for what it
is
a return to the barbaric practice
of the cash bail system
a return to a system that addresses
mental illness homelessness and poverty
with shackles and cages
i urge all my colleagues to vote red and
oppose this bill because it will have
very real and very dire consequences for
minorities homeless individuals and
those suffering from mental health
issues thank you mr speaker
the member from manchester
representative long is recognized to
speak in support of the committee report
thank you mr speaker i rise in support
of the other passes amended question i
agree people should not be detained in
jail simply because they can't afford to
pay the bail amount in 2018 i supported
the current statute however i've learned
and experienced in manchester the
unintended consequences of multiple
arrests of the same people on bail
as an alderman in manchester i've
i receive arrest statements frequently
and notice early on that the same people
were being arrested again for the same
crime i needed to explain to my
constituents why the same person for
example that damaged your car last week
trying to take things out of it was
arrested again for damaging your
neighbor's vehicle the next the
following week
i too represent
my constituents which are both
my state rep had in my automatic hat
i've also witnessed discussion within
specific groups that were mentioned by
the prior speaker that
that have made their colleagues they've
made their colleagues aware of the
criminal activity
not to be concerned about going around
breaking into cars
we're going to get arrested and i'm
guaranteeing you within two to three
hours we're going to get released that's
the conversation they're having this is
the this is what we've been hearing in
the city of manchester
not let alone the the
let alone the uh
the extra work extra
resources spent on our police force
repeatedly picking up these people
repeatedly week week after week after
week
this has no benefit to the person
arrested or to the neighborhoods
involved
let alone the resources spent
hospital 1476 is a start in addressing
the consequences realized today with
bail reform and i i will be supporting
the on to pass as amended thank you mr
speaker
the member from now sure representative
harriet gathered is recognized to speak
against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
hb
1476 has amended and mandate the
pre-trial incarceration of any
individual charged with any felony or
class a misdemeanor offense if they were
on release for any offense at the time
including a class b misdemeanor offense
that carries no jail time if convicted
this legislation legislation will not
make our community safer current law
already allows the court to detain
individuals pretrial if they are flight
risk or danger to the community
this
one-size-fits-all legislation will
deprive potentially thousands of granite
staters of their freedom without any
evidence that any of the individuals
pose a threat to our communities
this legislation is based in fear not
evidence
despite the fair-based rhetoric and
limited anecdotal stories from our law
enforcement leaders proponents of this
legislation has proved
no data to support their claims that the
current bail system makes new hampshire
less safe
this legislation will disproportionately
harm black people
new hampshire's criminal laws are
enforced with a staggering racial bias
for example in 2020
black people were 3.29 times more likely
to be arrested compared with white
people
for many low-level discretionary
offenses this disparity
were even more troubling including 4.8
times for marijuana possession despite
both groups using marijuana at roughly
the same rate
5.9 times for disorderly conduct
6.52 times for vagrancy
because black people are
disproportionately arrested they will
also be disproportionately incarcerated
under this legislation's mandatory
incarceration regime
in the midst of a national reckoning
around system racism and police violence
it is unconscionable that legislators
would expand the already
disproportionate incarceration of black
people in new hampshire
this legislation will expand the
criminalization of poverty in new
hampshire
personal reconnaissance bills was
implemented to ensure that people could
not afford bail could be released
assuming the court did not find them to
be a danger or flight risk
under this proposed legislation people
who are arrested while on pre-trial
release will be denied personal
reconnaissance bail thus setting up a
new wealth-based incarceration system
where those with wealth can purchase
their freedom
so i appoint you my colleagues that you
vote against the ought to pass for hp
1476. thank you mr speaker
we're down to the final speaker and this
isn't going to be a voice vote so maybe
find our seats the member from
manchester representative barry is
recognized to speak in support of the
committee report
thank you mr speaker and thank you to
the body for allowing this debate to
take place i know it's been a long day
and we've got more to go
i represent the south side of manchester
wards six and eight
when i door knocked and campaigned
i knocked on over 4 500 doors and when
you do that you would expect when you
meet a lot of voters and you would
expect to hear the traditional issues
guns abortion education
an overwhelming vast majority of my
constituents cited bail reform
because it is a manchester problem
for those of you who pay attention to
politics you know that me and my mayor
don't always get along
but we agree on this
the very first thing i did upon winning
my election before we were even sworn in
was meet with our police department to
try to look at ways to fix
pr bail or bail reform in general and
everyone was pointing fingers because
the reform that this body had just
passed was still taking effect
and we and i was told to wait
so we waited
mr speaker manchester is done waiting
the other communities that are affected
by this are done waiting
last year we just had our crime report
out and my one of the other members from
manchester referenced that report
property crime in manchester is up 10
percent
it's up 10 percent in manchester in one
year
and i want to talk about the specifics
of this bill because they often get
overlooked
does anybody guess what the current
standard is for being held
it's 72 hours
so what did we do to try to bring in as
many people as possible on this we
compromised and we shortened it to 36
hours you heard that correct if you vote
for this bill you are shortening the
amount of time that someone can legally
be held from the law as it is today
mr speaker
we are not trying to overturn the bail
reform that this body passed we are
talking about people who are already out
on bail
they are already out on bail and they
have been arrested again but again the
other side came to us and said can you
compromise and we said yes we will
because we want you on board so we
reduced the we reduced it for three
times for class b misdemeanors you have
to be arrested three times for a class b
misdemeanor before this kicks in
dwi is a class b misdemeanor
mr speaker manchester is done waiting
our communities are done waiting and i
urge you
this is a bipartisan bill from the
beginning it is bipartisan not one
democrats co-sponsors there were three i
urge you to vote ought to pass thank you
mr speaker
the house will be in order
representative jose's request a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
your seats
the house will come to order
the question before the house is the
majority committee report of acha pass
with amendment
representative newman is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill changes the
permissive roared may
to the mandatory word shall
mandating that decisions on bail and
release must be made by judges
who are only available during business
hours monday through friday
and if i know that this change
eliminates access to bail commissioners
for people who are affected by this bill
and prevents their access to due process
when judges are not available
even though they have only been charged
in our innocent until proven guilty
and when i asked one of the police
chiefs that testified
if this would be a better bill
if
judges were available
to make the judgments during
non-business hours at night and on
weekends
he said that it certainly would
so would i now press the red button to
oppose this bill
and continue to provide the same due
process to all people
regardless of when they are charged and
they are still innocent thank you
representative conley is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that this
bill retains the core tenants of new
hampshire's 2018 bail reform bill while
addressing cases when the same person is
arrested multiple times while already
out on bail
and if i know that this is not just a
manchester problem but a statewide
problem that affects
even my city of dover and other seacoast
communities
and if i know this bill is supported by
new hampshire's police chiefs and our
elected sheriffs and county attorneys of
both parties who know this issue better
than anyone would i then press the green
button
to support this important bill thank you
the questions on the majority committee
report are about to pass as amended this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative belanger
all right
all members present had an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
200 having voted 199 having voted in the
affirmative 134 on the negative the
committee reports adopted
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred house bill 1512 fn an
act relative to the parole of certain
prisoners having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it has been
expedient to legislate representative
terry roy for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
representative linda harry at guthrie
for the minority of the committee
the member from seabrook representative
abramson is recognized to speak against
the committee report
the house will be in order so we can
hear him please
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the itl motion on house
bill 1512 a bill providing a parole
hearing but not a guarantee of parole
for 189 inmates who are currently
serving life with life in prison without
possibility of parole
about half of states have
parole hearings for all inmates
[Music]
a 2001 to 2009 study commissioned by
congress showed that every forensic
method that had been used to convict
people up to that point had been fraught
with errors false positives false
negatives
and even junk science many of those junk
science methods that were used to
convict people have since been thrown
out by the courts
interrogation methods used to send
americans to prison for life have long
since been rejected as unreliable but
these people are still serving life
without parole right now in new
hampshire's prisons
on habeas corpus filings which the
opposition suggested was an alternative
judges are not allowed to order a new
trial unless a single piece of new
evidence would would likely overcome
everything that the prosecutor threw at
you and 99 percent of those habeas
corpus
filings
get rejected
those wrongly convicted overcharged over
sentenced or convicted of first-degree
homicide
for merely being an accomplice or
committing manslaughter have no real
evidentiary appeal
yet usually present little or no real
danger to society
and statistics have shown that about 15
to 20 percent of lifers would be
released on a parole hearing as in other
states and in some states it's over 25
percent the new hampshire civil
liberties union showed that once people
have served 25 years in prison there is
no more deterring effect to keeping
aging inmates in prison
promises
of medical parole opponents
parole by opponents of this bill were
false
the cost to the taxpayer of sending a
parade of medical specialists into our
prisons
every day
to treat inmates in their 70s and 80s
have been
horrendous the rising cost of the
taxpayers
for hiring all of these specialists and
having them take nearly an entire day
off just to go visit one inmate in
prison sometimes multiple times per
month
is astronomical
i spoke on the phone with chad evans a
man who physically couldn't possibly
have committed the crime that he cert
already served over 20 years for he told
me that in two decades
only one sick inmate
in all of his experience was released on
medical parole and only days before he
died
one parole member admitted
at a previous hearing public hearing
that if someone maintained their
innocence at the parole hearing they
would send them right back to prison
without a fair hearing
the irony is that those who are wrongly
convicted
if they maintain their innocence do not
get a chance at a parole hearing at all
under the current system
this bill was supported by citizens for
criminal justice reform by members of
new hampshire liberty alliance by the
new hampshire civil liberties union and
by hundreds of people around the state
who emailed wrote or even called
legislators asking for their support and
i'm requesting a roll call and asking
members to press the red button
the member from deerfield representative
roy is recognized to speak in support of
the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker we've
heard a lot of talk
on this bill about
about
people in jail for life sentences
without parole and about how difficult
it is to get a new trial
and how difficult it is to prove that
you didn't do it if you say you didn't
do it
let's talk for a second about something
else let's talk about victims
if you're sentenced to life in prison
without the possibility of parole it's
generally going to be for a heinous
murder or a horrible sexual offense
what this bill is going to do is it's
going to make people who thought that
they had put this behind them and moved
on with their lives have to relive
the horror that they went through to put
this person in jail in the first place
someone murders your child and they get
sentenced to life without parole
you start to be able to heal and move on
with your life but because for whatever
reason we decided now we're going to
give them parole hearings
every single victim of those people
those 186 people that are currently
serving life without parole are going to
have to relive the trauma of what was
done to them
just for this we heard testimony from
the parole board that they they would be
overwhelmed by this number of people
that wouldn't be it would back up the
people that deserve parole and delay
their hearings so for a second let's all
just pause
and think about victims
this is just i can't think of anything
more horrific to do to someone who's had
moved on with their lives
suffered trauma like this to be get a
letter in the mail and say oh you're
invited to a parole hearing for the
person that raped or murdered or did
whatever to your loved one now come and
testify again so that they can stay in
jail so mr speaker i would ask everyone
to to really think about their permanent
and and
support the inexpedient to legislate on
this bill thank you
representative abramson requests a roll
call vote is that sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded this
will be a division vote members take
receipts
can we get that mic on
mr speaker point of order
state your point of order i can't hear
anything
that's that's being said and i'm sitting
directly in front could you please
remind people on the margins
of the room to please be quiet
i will absolutely swing the gavel harder
all right let's take our seats i'm
pretty sure there's no good midnight
buffets in the area so
let's push the pace
the house will be in order the question
before the house is the majority
committee report of inexpedience or
legislate
representative abramson is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that a majority of states in this
country have parole hearings already
for just such for
sorry
for all cases including life
cases
if i know that eight members of the
criminal justice committee agreed not
just this this year but also the last
time that the same bill was introduced
if i know
that far far worse than the traumatic
experience of having to go through the
trial the first time is discovering that
someone else has admitted
to the murder of a family member of
yours but if i also know that even in
instances where other people have
admitted that the person in prison is is
either not guilty or was not there or
was only an accomplice
that those people do not get a new trial
in most cases would i now press the red
button so that they can at least get a
parole hearing
representative roy is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if
i know that people that are in jail for
life without parole have had a fair
trial have had appeals
and are continued
available appeals to them if new
evidence were presented
and further mr speaker if i care more
about victims being re-victimized than i
do about criminals who have been
convicted would i vote itl thank you
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpediency
legislate this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
division sorry my bad
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
182 having voted in the affirmative 127
and the negative the committee report is
adopted
the committee on criminal justice and
public safety to which was referred
house bill 1539 and act relative to the
removal of certain information from the
new hampshire state police website
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative john boarding
for the committee the question is on the
committee report of an expedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
guys have it and the committee reports
adopted
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred house bill 1600 and
act relative to the use of body cameras
by law enforcement during an interview
or interrogation having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative terry
roy for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
ray newman from the minority of the
committee
for what reason does the member rise
thank you mr speaker i wish to make a
motion to table hb 1600 representative
abbas moves to lay house bill 1600 on
the table are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye all those
opposed nay
house bill 1600 is laid on the table
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred house bill 1668 an
act requiring a background check prior
to any commercial firearm sale having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative john burke for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative casey conley for the
minority of the committee
the member from manchester
representative bradley is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
this bill is a sensible measure designed
to keep guns out of the hands of felons
and other prohibited parties
currently anyone purchasing a firearm
from a federally licensed firearm dealer
is required to pass a criminal
background check
according to the fbi roughly 92 percent
of those checks are rendered almost
instantly and at the same time any risk
to public safety safety
is minimized because the process lowers
the risk of a person prohibited from
owning a gun from getting a gun simply
by walking into a gun shop with a credit
card
however
the federal law on background checks
only applies to sales conducted by
federally licensed
firearm dealers
this situation effectively exempts
commercial transactions between private
parties
what this bill will do is close that gap
in ways that allow
sensible exemptions
selling a gun to someone you personally
know
the sale is exempt as long as that
person isn't a prohibited party
this bill specifically focuses on
commercial sales and exchanges to
parties not known by the seller
please push the red button so another
motion can be made
thank you
the member from salem representative
abbas is recognized to speak in support
of the committee report and will
somebody in the back swing the interim
doors shut
we appreciate that members take their
conversations out there it does not help
if the doors are wedged open
thank you
thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the committee's
recommendation of inexpedient to
legislate
in regards to this bill there is some
confusing language in this bill and you
may have this is a familiar bill we had
it last term for those who are in the
body last term
and first it
defines a commercial sale to include a
gift or any type of exchange
including private exchange so when you
read the exceptions
section which is on page two
well it says non-commercial sales
i did not know what that meant last time
i read this bill i still don't know what
it means today whether that exception
would apply to a gift or a private gift
or whatnot
under existing law today there are
federal background checks that are done
whenever there is a
commercial sale done and when i say
commercial said i mean you go to a store
and purchase it from a licensed firearm
dealer
the issue really is what do these
background checks actually do
there was information provided to the
committee
that out of the people who are
prohibited from possessing a firearm
under the law
of those individuals 99 of those people
actually acquire those firearms either
through an illegal straw purchase which
is when someone
intentionally purchases a firearm for
someone knowing that that person's not
allowed to have one or
they bought it illegally on the street
it deals with the one percent excuse me
it deals with the 99
of
those illegal ones this bill actually
applies to the one percent
one percent
when we hear about we're trying to
prevent handgun violence and we're
trying to prevent people who are not
supposed to possess firearms
who are not allowed to we're not
focusing on the overwhelming majority of
the issue being raised by the bill
however
the issues and we heard a lot of
testimony about background checks where
someone was not allowed to have a
firearm under the law but still managed
to get a firearm in their possession
in those situations examples provided to
us the person did
there was a background checks performed
and for whatever reason there was a
failure of the background check system
that is was operated by the federal
government
which we have no control over
so
i would say that the intent of this bill
perhaps even well intended it does not
accomplish any of the objectives
presented to the committee
for that reason i ask you to join me in
pushing that green button and support
the committee's recommendation of index
being to legislate thank you mr speaker
representative burt requests a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
your seats
the house will be in order
representative muse is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that firearms background
checks can keep guns out of the hands of
felons and bad actors under protective
orders and if i know that this bill
closes a key loophole in our laws
requiring the involvement of a licensed
firearms dealer to perform a background
check for commercial sales between
private parties
and if i know background checks would
provide peace of mind to many gun owners
who wouldn't want to sell a weapon to a
felon
or to anybody who's subject to a
domestic violence protective order
then would i press the red button to
overturn the itl motion so another
motion can be made thank you
representative burt is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
mr speaker if i know house bill 1668
will make gifts
or loaning of a firearm between friends
family
and neighbors into a crime
mr speaker if i know those who that came
to the committee to support this bill
did not explain how it would have
stopped any of the tragedies
that the country has witnessed in recent
years such as newtown connecticut the
criminal murdered his own mother and
stole her gun aurora colorado
the murderer passed a background check
in tuscan
arizona also the murder passed a
background check
and lastly mr speaker if i know house
bill 1668
has several times in the past been
before us and it has always been
rejected as a huge government overreach
into private activities would i now
press the green button to itl house bill
thank you mr speaker
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedience
legislate this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
okay
all good
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
179 having voted in the affirmative 144
in the negative the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
education which was referred to house
bill 1047 an act relative to the
chartered public school joint
legislative oversight committee having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative ralph bohm for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative linda tanner for the
minority of the committee
this is a division vote we're going
straight to the vote
theresa
okay the question before the house is
the majority committee report of an
expedient to legislate
representative tan is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
hb 1047 revised revises and revitalizes
the charter school joint legislative
oversight committee that's already in
statute
by changing the committee composition
representative yes
these are parliamentary inquiries i'm
sorry yes if i know
okay if i know hb 1047 revises and
revitalizes the charter school joint
legislative oversight committee already
in statute by changing the committee
composition and requiring yearly reports
and if i know that we have had
a significant growth in the number of
charter schools in our state in the past
six years
yet this committee has not filed a
report since 2011 and the last committee
meeting was held in 2016.
and if i know the charter school program
should have legislative oversight
by a committee that meets regularly and
presents a yearly review of the charter
school program its operations
performance and innovative practices
would i now push the red button to
overturn the itl
so motion of otp could be introduced
thank you
representative litchfield is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill repeals the
current statute for the charter school
legislative oversight committee
and then replaces it with little change
if i know that the major change in house
bill 1047 is actually adding busy work
for the state board of education by
requiring
an annual report on charter school
effectiveness to the oversight committee
would i now itl this unnecessary bill
by voting with the committee majority
and pressing the green button
the questions on the majority committee
report have been expedient to legislate
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll be pressing the green
button if you're opposed to be pressing
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
170.
173 having voted in the affirmative 152
and the negative the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
education which was referred house bill
1051 an act relative to state board of
education rules for credit for
alternative extended learning and
work-based programs having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
rick ladd for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative linda
tanner for the minority of the committee
the member from georgia's mills
representative chandler is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
through the learn everywhere program and
the ed choice vouchers parents have
become consumers for their child's
education
our public schools provide a complete
profile for the
important considerations and policies
for the schools such as the course of
study
grading policies discipline policies
co-curricular activities a listing of
the staff and requirements for
graduation
school guidance counselors and staff
advisors help parents and students
negotiate through their four years of
high school offerings career pathways
in the course of studies and possible
career and technical opportunities
advanced courses leading to college
graduation and credit
school to work opportunities electives
and stem and steam
community service and the new hampshire
scholars program to name a few
when parents seek alternative coursework
outside the public school for their
child
they need to know the specifics of those
alternative offerings
the policies the course work hands-on
work
experiences and how these programs might
align with the career pathways
graduation credits
or college credits given at the at the
public school
recently the state board of of education
and the department of education
have started
through departmental rules to develop an
online listing that offers a limited
consumer guide to alternative schools
vendors and programs
hb 1051 puts the requirement for the
department of education
for vetting and publishing a consumer
listing into statute
parents should be able to know before
they commit money and time to a program
the procedures for student safety
grading or competencies a profile of the
staff discipline and dismissal policies
refunds if the program does not fit
their child and a description of the
documentation of completion that they
can then present to the state school
board and the local school district for
graduation credits
alternate alternative and work based
learning programs offered a great
experience for students that adds to
their education and inspires them in a
variety of areas outside the school
curriculum
this bill is requiring the department of
education to add to their centralized
list of profiles of alternative
education offerings
information that is necessary for
parents as consumers
to make an informed decision
about vendors extended learning and work
based opportunities i hope you will
support parents by voting against the
itl so an otp motion can be introduced
thank you
final speaker the member from haverhill
representative lads recognized to speak
in support of the committee report
thank you very much mr speaker
for the record we have no vouchers in
the state of new hampshire
this is about 10 51
this bill would allow local school
boards to reject
credit that has been earned through
programs that have been approved through
a rigorous application process at the
state board of education namely the
learn everywhere program
since established in law the learn
everywhere program has successfully
provided high school students the
opportunity to earn credits
toward graduation
through expanded learning experiences
outside the standard school day
approved learning everywhere programs to
name a few
include the boys and girls club in
souhegan valley first robotics the new
hampshire academy of science
north maine music signum academy the
seacoast
science center
and seacoast on united these education
programs provide a wide range of
approved credit courses in areas such as
biology
ap biology chemistry
music
foreign languages
fiscal education business and physics
while offering high school students the
opportunity to expand learning
opportunities and gain career awareness
beyond those subjects subject areas
taught or available at their local
school
this is why the new hampshire department
of education designed the learn
everywhere program
an innovative approach to learning that
takes place
and that takes the state's existing
philosophy laws and rules and expands
and makes available enriching
educational opportunities available that
meet and exceed state academic standards
the approval process for learn
everywhere program and those providers
is thorough
a potential vendor
offender's application is carefully
reviewed
vetted to ensure accountability and
competency attainment
background checks
are required
health safety and fire code documents
must be received this bill is if this
bill is passed the way it is right now
hopefully it won't be
would allow a local school board to
overrule and deny graduation credit
earned through this challenging state
board approved program
where and how students acquire
graduation credit
is not the exclusive right of the
traditional brick and mortar
system
this bill is not in the best interest of
students
it's about
control
please support the committee
recommendation
representative chan has requested a
division vote this will be a division
vote members please take our seats
i also come to order the question is on
the majority committee report of an
expedient to legislate
representative hall is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i believe that it should be the
responsibility of the state board of
education to adopt rules which establish
a process for the application vetting
and approval of learn everywhere vendors
and
mr speaker if i believe that having a
centralized location at the doe for a
list of the approved vendors
would help parents and school districts
explore and examine options for these
alternative extended learning work based
programs that offer credit for
graduation
would i now vote no on the itl motion
and push the red button so that another
motion can be brought forward
representative ladd is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you very much mr speaker only 32
bills left
if i know the learn everywhere program
offers new hampshire students a 21st
century education that extends well
beyond the four walls of the brick and
mortar classroom
and if i know the learn everywhere
program increases and enriches learning
options for students who may not have a
wide range of graduation required
courses
in their local school that and also that
best fit their learning needs
if i know this bill is more about
control than it is for the best learning
opportunity for a student would i then
support this extraordinary program
along with the committee's itl
recommendation by pressing the green
button thank you
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll be pressing the green
button if you're opposed you'll be
pressing pushing the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
of all members presidents had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
174 having voted in the affirmative 147
having voted in the negative the
committee report is adopted
i drank out of that
majority of the committee on education
which is referred house bill 1090
relative to teaching on discrimination
in public schools having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpensive
to legislate
senator
a very cloud for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendations the bill ought
to pass representative sue mullen for
the minority of the committee
what reason does a member rise rise to
make a motion stage in motion to table
the motion is to
lay house bill 109-0 on the table
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
no tanner
the motion before us is to table house
bill 109-0
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
tanner for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that hb
1090 deals with the publicly unpopular
prohibition on teaching discrimination
bill
that has never had a full debate on the
floor
and if i know we must address
this destructive censorship of speech
the removal of books the spread of
mistrust misinformation and untruths
about our schools and teachers and the
disrespect to story and experience of
those who suffer from discrimination
would i now vote red on the tabling
motions so that we could bring this bill
forward and debate it thank you
chair recognizes representative cadelli
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that discrimination of any
kind is unacceptable in public
workplaces and in education
but if i also know that the recently
passed discrimination law does not
restrict or stifle any teacher
instruction in the classroom
would i then support the tabling motion
so that we can get on the rest with the
rest of our thirty education bills by
pressing the green button
the motion before us is the table house
bill 109-0
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
165 voting yeah 153 voting nay
house bill 1090 is laid on the table
the next bill before us is a division
vote with just parliamentary inquiries
so members stay in your seats
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred house bill
1113 back prohibiting the department of
education and the state board of
education from directing or limiting
school instructional options such as
remote learning have been considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate
president glenn cordelli for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same of being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative
reporter for the minority of the
committee
this will be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
porter for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker this is my first
time at the well in two years
it feels pretty good
if i know our community schools
now have the technology and skills
needed to keep learning happening
remotely when it is unsafe to have
students physically present in a school
building
and if i know current department of
education rules limits the use of remote
learning to snow days only
all other use will result in makeup days
in june
but if i know the proposed amendment
allows the emergency use of remote
learning for up to five days per year
thus addressing committee concerns
would i then remember
the member will suspend
state your point state your point of
order
thank you
mr speaker um i believe the motion on
the floor is itl but we're hearing about
an amendment that is not even uh on the
floor at this point
[Music]
i'm speaking to my motion sir
she's
she she is speaking to the ito motion
so
so far everybody has been pretty good
today so i'm going to give everybody a
little bit
of latitude
and i will put the hammer down if i have
to you may continue
state your point of order
you told us this was only pis
this is a parliamentary inquiry
if it's a pi
then how can she be speaking to her
motion
she's doing a parliamentary inquiry
representative
house will come to order the member may
continue
when i now press the red button so local
schools
so local schools can stay nimble and
flexible when needing to keep students
safe and learning happening thank you mr
speaker
the chair
the chair recognizes representative ladd
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know remote learning served a
purpose during the recent covet pandemic
however
i also know that the recent coveted
remote learning model had a downside
with respect to student academic
achievement and student social emotional
wellness especially in respect to
economically disadvantaged students
minorities and for students with
individual education plans
and if i know this bill would prohibit
the department of education
or state board of education in limiting
attendance options such as remote
learning
would i then support the committee
recommendation by pressing the green
button thank you
the motion before us
is the majority report have been
expedient to legislate on house bill
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're approached you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
hey
mr speaker
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the vote
166 voting a 154 volninae the committee
report is adopted
no debate
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred house bill 1114
an act relative to education service
providers under the education freedom
account program have been considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate president of glenn cordelli
from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with senator patricia cornell from
the minority of the
committee motion before us
is the inexpedient to legislate
on house bill 1114 are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the ice highs have it and the committee
report is adopted
[Music]
everyone will stay in their feet sweet
seats we have another one
that is just a
division and pis
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred house bill 1115
and act relative
to record of education attainment under
the educational freedom account program
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that
it's inexpedient to legislate
representative deborah hobson for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendations the bill ought to pass
senator patricia cornell from the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative cornell
need to be in their fury if we're in the
voting room thank you mister we're in
the voting
just just a minute we're in the voting
road mode representatives into your
seats
members take your seats
chair recognizes representative cornell
for parliamentary inquiry
if i know education freedom account
students should be held to the same
academic stud standards as public school
students and i know that this bill
addresses concerns heard during
committee regarding academic
accountability and transparency and if i
know that public and public chartered
school students all take the annual
statewide assessment and i believe that
any student receiving public funds
should be held to the same
accountability requirements and their
academic progress needs to be available
to the public would i now vote no and
press the red button so another motion
can be brought forward
the chair recognizes representative ford
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this is yet another
attack on the education freedom account
program
if i know that it requires efa students
to take the public school state
assessment and eliminates the other
assessment options
and if i know that this removes student
freedoms from the freedom program
would i now itl this attack on the
education freedom account program by
pressing the green button
thank you mr speaker the question before
us is the majority report of inexpensive
legislator in house bill 1115.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're approached you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
represent mullen
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
163 voting 150 voting aid the committee
reports adopted
if members will stay in their seats we
have a
one-on-one debate and a roll call
request
majority committee on education to which
was referred house bill 1120.
act relative to education service
providers under the education freedom
accounts program considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate presenter glenn cordelli
from the majority of the committee
the not minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator sue mullen for the minority
of the committee chair recognizes
representative mullen
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise today in opposition to
house education majority's
recommendation of itl for house bill
1120.
bill is really about two things
quality of instruction and student
safety
as they apply to students participating
in the education freedom account program
many minority members of house ed along
with their constituents have expressed
numerous concerns regarding the
qualification and background checks of
service providers who are paid with
state funds to teach our children in
non-traditional settings
house bill 1120 addresses a number of
these concerns most specifically
assuring
that education service providers have a
proven track record of both academic
success and financial viability
that instructional providers referring
to themselves as a school or offering a
comprehensive program
seek non-public school approval as
outlined in our current ed 400 rules
that individuals and programs comply
with all the applicable local health
health and safety standards and codes
particularly those outlined by the 2016
governor's school safety preparedness
task force
and that all providers who have direct
contact with our children complete
pass and submit the criminal history
background check required under rsa 189
colon 13a to the department of education
what the bill requires would not be
unique to new hampshire
georgia oklahoma utah mississippi
washington d.c
wisconsin and north carolina all have
required some version of provision one
in an attempt to preempt financial loss
or fraud
arkansas indiana mississippi oklahoma
d.c louisiana ohio maine maryland
vermont and wisconsin all require some
form of accreditation
or state approval of proposed curriculum
to be used that meets state standards
arkansas has been the guiding light in
terms of health and safety standards in
response to some horror stories coming
out of dc and indiana
and our own joint legislative committee
on administrative rules when discussing
the education freedom accounts program
said
there is no provision in the statute to
require that education service providers
get a criminal background check
and no stipulation that a negative
background check will result in a bar
from participation
in the efa program
if these are needed the statute will
need to be amended
so
i stand before you today because efas
are here
and they need some work
regardless of how any of us feel about
the impact of the program on our ability
to fund existing public schools
we currently have almost 2 000 kids
participating in a program that has
inadequate guard rails
financial stability
measurable educational standards health
and safety first
no criminals with kids
surely these are not revolutionary or
objectionable goals
my concern is that we have put the cart
before the horse
and that this program went into effect
before we had the opportunity to work
out all the kinks
it's now going to take all of us to move
that horse
please vote no on the majority
recommendation of itl so that another
motion may be made
thank you mr speaker
we're on the final speaker
representative mullen has requested a
roll call as that's officially seconded
it is officially seconded
members will take their seats we're on
the final call we're on the final
speaker
chair recognizes representative cordelli
thank you mr speaker
this bill wasn't was written in relation
to a voucher program
but we all know that there are no
vouchers in new hampshire
we have an education freedom account
program that provides provides a variety
of education options for parents not
just going to a different school
the litany of states you just heard
they were all
in relation to voucher programs where a
voucher is given to a student to go to a
particular school
hp 1120
would require
education freedom accounts service
providers to have a proven academic
success success record and have
background checks
if an efa student is going to let's say
a private school
that would be the case
there would be background checks
and it all sounds good
but with the education freedom accounts
how does a service provider
prove academic success or have a
background check if they're providing
computers to the student or selling
curriculum to the student
how about a home school mom who is
taking in
education freedom account kids from the
neighborhood
how does she prove academic success for
the past year
is she going to have to get a background
check
this the necessary requirements
for the service providers are in law
and in rules including information about
background checks on service providers
the bill requires for service providers
do not make sense for our education
freedom account program
the committee voted itl and so should
you
the motion before us is the majority
report of any spinning to legislator on
house bill 1120 this is a roll call vote
members will take their seats
so
the chair recognizes representative hall
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i believe that all public and
non-public school education programs
funded by new hampshire taxpayers money
must be approved by the new hampshire
department of education
and mr speaker
if i believe that all education freedom
account service providers must be able
to demonstrate financial sustainability
and measurable academic success
and mr speaker if i believe that
criminal background checks must be
mandatory in public and non-public
schools in order to provide safe
learning environments for all new
hampshire students but i now vote no on
the itl motion and push the red button
so that another motion can be brought
forward
chair i recognize the representative
ladd for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know this bill would require an efa
service provider to comply with a number
of conditions that are already required
by federal and state laws and recently
approved rules
and if i know this bill
would even require a mom
who is homeschooling neighborhood
children to have a background check
and lastly if i know this is one of many
bills recently submitted to the
education committee to obstruct
the efa program that is providing well
over 1800 new hampshire students an
education that best meets their needs
would i then support education choice by
pressing the green button thank you
the motion before us is the majority
report of an expedition to legislator on
house bill 1120 it's the roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
members will be in their seats while
we're voting
oh
that would help wouldn't it
[Music]
thank you
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
the state of the vote
165 voting yeah 155 voting a committee
report is adopted
for what reason november rise
can i move that the remarks of the
previous debate be placed in the
permanent journal
i i i'm sorry
sorry can i
move that the remarks of the previous
debate be placed in the permanent
journal
the member moves that the remarks of the
previous debate be placed in the
permanent journal
without
objection
without without without objection
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred house bill 1131
act relative to facial covering policies
for schools considered the same report
the same with the following amendment
and recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment senator glenn
cadelli for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate
the majority amendment is
h
printed in house record 10 a pages 14
through 15.
the motion before us is on the
amendment 0
9 8 h are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it and the amendment is
adopted the bill being on second reading
opened a further amendment
representative tanner moves floor
amendment 1083-h
it is in your seat pockets
and the chair recognizes
representative tanner
thank you mr speaker i offer floor
amendment 1083 h
this bill is about the mask issue which
particularly in schools has been
extremely contentious and divisive issue
hb 1131
the main
main bill
offers a rigid solution mass by
prohibiting school boards and other
public agencies from adopting enforcing
or implementing a policy that requires
students or members of the public to
wear a facial covering
this amendment speaks to
the third section of that bill
which requires
teachers to follow
requires teachers not to require mass
and
puts them in double jeopardy either
they
are following the school board policy
which if they
do not follow that policy they can be
fired for insubordination
or
if they do the opposite
and
don't wear them don't require the mass
or or do require the mass they are taken
before the code of conduct by the
department of education
and they lose their teacher
certification
this is double jeopardy
and that's why i would like this part of
the
bill removed through this amendment
so that teachers would not be put in
this situation where they're damned if
they do and damned if they don't so
thank you
there is going to be a division vote on
this amendment so members will be taking
their seats we're at the last speaker
chair recognizer senator blazik
this amendment uh would as the previous
speaker said
remove the responsibility of the
educator to follow the law
so essentially a district would never
actually
make a mask policy if this bill passes
because
that would be illegal
so therefore if an educator like a
principal or a teacher
decides to violate this law
and
implement a mask policy they should be
held accountable
representative blasic requests the roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote on the amendment
members take their seats
know
the motion before us is the floor
amendment
by representative mullen
this is going to be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
mullen for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr chair mr chair thank you mr
speaker mr speaker
if i know that teachers are expected to
follow the directors of their
administrators the superintendent and
local school boards or they're
considered insubordinate
and if i know the procedures and
policies for supervision and
disciplinary actions are the joint
effort of school boards and bargaining
units and not within the control of the
individual teacher
would i now acknowledge the reality of
the chain of command for our educators
by pushing the green button to support
the amendment
thank you
chair recognizes representative cadelli
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that teachers who violate the
law
and are insubordinate should be held
accountable
and that this floor amendment would
remove that accountability where i now
press the red button
this is going to be a roll call vote
on the
floor amendment the tanner floor
amendment
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative
members president had an opportunity to
vote
house will attend to the state of the
152 voting a
168 voting a
the floor amendment fails
we're on to the
back to the original majority report
about to pass as amended
the chair recognizes representative
tanner
thank you mr speaker
um
i don't have to tell anyone here no
matter which side of the mask issue
you're on that it's been extremely
contentious and divisive like i said
before
we have many bills that are dealing with
mass in several different committees
unfortunately schools have taken the
brunt of much of the controversy
with no clear requirement or support
from the department of education on how
to provide an adequate education keep
students and staff safe during cove the
covet pandemic and at the same time
deliver the support
provide the lunches
maintain a safety net
schools public schools were on their own
to come up with solutions and procedures
all of us did this the past two years
schools tried to make the best decisions
based on what information was given them
from state agencies the governor's
office
the state chief medical
officer
hb 1131 offers an extreme and rigid
solution to the mask issue
and then enforces it with a sledgehammer
this bill requires public schools to
adopt a policy
that will prohibit schools
or school districts from adopting
enforcing or implementing a policy that
requires
students
members of the public attending meetings
or coming onto school property from
wearing a mask
or covering facial covering
inform enforcement of hb 1131 gives any
person claiming to be aggrieved by a
violation of this bill
including the attorney general
the ability to initiate a civil action a
lawsuit
against the school the school district
the school board or any other public
education agency
did i mention the sledgehammer
and did i have a floor amendment
in section three of this bill is it
totally uncalled for attack on teachers
a teacher who follows a mask requirement
that might be at the direction of the
school
the governor the state medical officer
or the department of education
risks being fired for not following
employment procedures
if the teacher follows the measure
outlined in this bill by not requiring a
mask
they may risk losing their teaching
credential their license
their very livelihood by violating the
code of conduct
this is making an employee choose
between getting fired
or losing their teaching license and not
being able to teach
this is the true definition of double
jeopardy
that is the sledgehammer approach
this is an extreme measure to block a
common proven public health procedure to
slow the airborne transmission of
diseases
this is an extreme measure that attacks
schools and teachers
who are doing their best under
unprecedented circumstances
this is an extreme measure that puts
schools in double jeopardy of meeting
their responsibility of keeping students
and staff as safe as they can
under the guidance of the chief medical
officer of our state and the governor's
emergency orders
and the center for disease control for
the federal government
and complying with this restrictive
policy
i urge you to vote red
so that an otp
on on the otp for this so an itl can be
offered thank you
senator blasic has requested a roll call
we're down to our last speaker is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote rem members
take your seats
chair recognizes representative blazik
thank you mr speaker
hb 1131 as amended is first and foremost
a parental rights bill
it allows parents in public schools to
make the best choice for their child in
regards to facial coverings
proponents of universal mass mandates in
schools
have yet to conclusively prove that mass
are helpful and that they do no harm
to date there have been no randomized
clinical control trials of masks in
children in masks
champions of mass mandates might cite
the bangladesh study that not only used
was riddled with severe design flaws but
also found that cloth mass which are the
mass used by the majority of students in
schools had no effect and surgical mass
had a statistically insignificant effect
they might also cite the recent cdc
promoted survey study of schools but
again this study was severely flawed
of thousands of people surveyed they
only got four tenths of one percent
response rate
coveted uh cases were based on contact
tracing but in many locations if the
student was masked they were not traced
and overall they found a significant
rise in all infections in the
mass-mandated schools
the list of flawed studies goes on from
there but suffice it to say that there
is no conclusive evidence that we are
helping the students the teachers or the
community by forcing children to wear
masks
but over the last two years papers have
started to emerge showing harms to
children there are now studies showing
the physical emotional psychological and
educational detriments to children from
mass mandates
testimony in the hearing for this bill
was heart-wrenching as parents shared
their stories including a child who
attempted suicide
and extreme
anxiety was a
contributing factor to her depression
numerous speech pathologists wrote
testimony about the severe speech
development harms they are seeing from
masking
this cannot be allowed to continue any
longer we are not conferring any benefit
to these students by forcing them to
wear a mask and we are potentially
harming them
dhhs recently changed their indoor
masking guidance and doe and the
governor announced that the school
systems had to drop their mass mandates
but to date some districts still have
mask requirements and refuse to drop
them
in addition several school systems have
pledged to mask the children every
winter for cold and flu season
i urge you to vote ought to pass on this
bill so that we can finally end the
unscientific and potentially harmful
mandates and allow parents to make the
best decisions for their children
this will be a roll call vote members
will take your seats
the house will be in order
the chair recognizes representative
mullen for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that this bill as
written
eliminates the superintendent of schools
from the public school chain of command
of decision making
if i know that it ignores the board of
directors at the chartered public school
and if i know that this bill opens up
the possibility of civil litigation by
any aggrieved party towards a school
school district school board or other
public education agency and weaponizes
the teacher code of conduct
and if i believe that the unintended
consequences of encouraging litigation
over collaboration
will shortchange both our students and
our constituents would i now push the
red button to oppose the majority
recommendation of otpa thank you
chair recognizes representative cordelli
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i know that the state has said that
masks should be an individual choice
if i know that there was an error on the
pink sheet on this bill
if i know that for too long schools have
ignored the education impact and harm to
children of wearing masks all day
and if i agree with the recent headline
the educational cost of face mask
coverings is far better established than
the benefits of mandates
what i now say enough is enough
and press the green button
house will be in order
the motion before us is the majority
report of octopass has amended on house
bill 1131. this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
166 voting a 157 voting nay
committee report is adopted mr speaker
for what reason remember rise
i moved to place the remarks of the
previous debate in the permanent journal
the motion before us is to plate
place the
recent debate in the permanent journal
without objection
okay
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred house bill 1132
enact relative to applications for a
charter conversion school have been
considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
representative alicia leakes for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate
president arthur ellison for the
minority of the committee the amendment
is 09708
and record 10a page 15.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes guys have it the amendment is
adopted chair recognizes
representative
woodcock to speak against the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
hb 1132
this bill is not focused on improving
public education not one iota
which is surprising to me as it came
from the chair
of the education committee the havel
representative
you think
that education improvement and
accountability would be the primary
focus
nope
not in this bill
as a matter of fact
it doesn't help families on vouchers on
education saving accounts or even home
schoolers
none of those groups
have taken a priority which have taken a
priority time
and concerns in this session
seem to be accounted so what does a
charter school conversion
bill really mean and do
first
it means that a few people can show up
or even pack a regular annual meeting of
the school board
we know how many sometimes come to those
meetings
not many
and then vote to convert
a school one school not all the schools
not every school in the district just
one school
so let's use town x elementary school
so this small group of citizens of the
town
vote to convert town x elementary school
to a charter
in the current law
as it stands now this can happen
but the teachers must want in
the school principal must contour
the superintendent gets a voice and of
course the locally elected school board
the people's representative
why would you want all those people to
buy into a plan and agree to make it
work
because they're the ones that are
responsible for the hard work and the
effort that will be needed to make this
work
in the days that charter schools were
first created it was by the teachers who
wanted to create a school maybe one with
a thematic mission or math and science
stem or focus on arts and other areas it
was the teachers that created the school
but
under this bill
those educators that want to work
creatively outside the boundaries of the
traditional school structure
those who want to build a better school
are not even in the loop
the administrators not even considered
and yep no superintendent oversight or
support required
when asked in testimony of the sponsor
why we want this bill what would it do
well the answer was it would save money
no need for library staff we can use the
town library phys that instruction will
be at local couples clubs and teams
doesn't seem like a sound educational
reason to me
so the teachers in this school x
they can come but be transferred but
they can't stay in their current union
they can't stay in their current
association
as a matter of fact it's a charter
school
only 50 percent of the teachers i even
need to be certified
custodians administrative assistants
school nurse yep they can come but they
can't stay in their association or union
either
so let's see
the new trustees not the elected school
board members will negotiate a new pay
wage benefits conditions and the staff
will take it or leave it
so to summarize
take all educators and professionals out
of the decision
bust all the unions
hire only half the number of certified
teachers outsource the use of town
facilities and the support staff be
necessary
i don't know about you but that sure
doesn't sound like a sound educational
model for teachers staff parents and the
students
is that a school that you want your
child or grandchild to attend
i don't
please vote no in the stp thank you
we're down to our last speaker
and this is going to be a division vote
so the sooner members take their seats
the sooner we can continue moving on
members take your seats this is going to
be a division vote we're down to the
last speaker
chair recognizes representative alicia
leakers
speak in favor of the committee report
yeah rather than the teachers
it would be
the people who live in the town the
taxpayers
the parents the parents of the students
they'd be the ones making the decisions
and any of the teachers superintendent
principal who lived in the town they'd
be making the decisions too
because this would put it to a vote of
the people in the town and a two-thirds
majority the member will suspend
the member has a right to be heard
i understand everybody's coming into the
chamber do it quietly
member may continue
we put it to a two-thirds vote of the
residents of the town
and it is the resident's school
the student school
and those are the ones who should be
making the decision but the other part
of that is the charter schools if you
want a charter school
it does have different rules they're
much looser and if the school's not
working i think the taxpayers and the
parents should be able to choose
something that they believe will work a
lot better
and this is
for the ch for the for the children as
opposed to for the teachers unions this
is for the children
thank you
the motion before us is the majority
report about the passage amendment on
house bill 1132 this is going to be a
division vote a roll call has been
has been
ordered offered by representative luno
as that sufficiently second is it is
sufficiently seconded members will take
their seats this is a roll call vote
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto pass has amended this is
going to be a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative ellison for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that removing teachers from the
charter school conversion process
will result in the voiding of existing
labor agreements between school staff
and local school boards
and if i know that instruction in new
conversion charter schools will be
provided by teachers 50 percent of whom
will be uncertified by any educational
agency
and if i believe that this bill is an
attempt to weaken public school systems
in our state would i now push the red
button so that another motion could be
brought forward thank you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative vlad for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you very much mr speaker
mr speaker if i know the current process
for a local school board to convert a
public school
into a public conversion charter school
requires written approval of the
principal
and superintendent
along with support of two-thirds of the
teachers
above and beyond school board and annual
meeting approval
and if i know that many of these
educators may not even live
in the community or school district
and if i know this bill eliminates
consent from the above paid employees
and places decision making on citizens
by requiring a positive vote of the
school board and two-thirds vote at the
regular
annual meeting
would i then support this needed change
by pressing the green button
the motion before us is the majority
report of autopass has amended on house
bill 1132 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
so
the wall members president had an
opportunity to vote
i also attend the state of the vote
166 voting yay 157 voting native
committee
this button
164 voting 848 voting a the committee
report is adopted
committee on education to which was
referred house bill 1137 and act
relative to the duty of school boards to
provide education having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative ralph
bone for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it
the committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred house bill 1152
act relative to verification of eligible
students and the education freedom
account program we consider the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is in expedient
to legislate representative rick ladd
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being will agree
with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator david luno from the
minority of the committee
the motion before us is
the most uh the majority committee
report of any speeding to legislate are
you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and it's an expedient
alleged the committee reports adopted mr
speaker
all right
if members will stay in their seats we
have a
request for a roll call and we're just
having pis
so members stay in your seats majority
committee on education to which was
referred house bill 1190 act relative to
rulemaking by the state board of
education for compliance with federal
provisions having considered the same
report the same with the recommendations
the bill ought to pass senator deborah
hopson for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and be an
edible degree when the majority report
with the following resolution resolves
that is in expedient to legislate
senator march reporter from the minority
of the committee
the chair recognizes
representative porter for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know the passage of this
bill will not affect the state's
obligation to follow federal mandates
funded or not
but if i know not following those
mandates could result in the loss of
many millions of dollars of federal
funds
schools and the department of education
rely on
to provide programs and services
and if i know some of the students most
grievously hurt by the loss of these
funds if the member if the member could
suspend for a minute
i made a little boo-boo i forgot to ask
for a second on the requirement
requisite firm or roll call so is that
sufficiently seconded
it is
it is not sufficiently seconded we're
not going to pop up at the last minute
this will be
this will be a division vote could you
start it again uh representative yeah i
begin again sir
start the beginning thank you
if i know the passage of this bill will
not affect the state's obligation to
follow federal mandates funded or not
but if i know
not following those mandates could
result in the loss of many millions of
dollars of federal funds
schools and the department of education
rely on to provide programs and services
and if i know some of the students most
grievously hurt by the loss of these
funds would be our most vulnerable and
those with special learning needs
then would i press the red button to
overturn the ought to pass motion so
another can be made thank you mr speaker
gee i recognize representative cadelli
for parliamentary anchoring
thank you mr speaker
if i know that too often the federal
government has mandated our new
hampshire educational policies
and if i know that we have common core
because of the bribery by the federal
government and the state board of
education going along with it in hopes
of getting money from the feds
would i now press the green button and
say no more no more
the house will be in order
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass on house bill
1190 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you opposed to press the red button
voting stations were open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
166 voting 146
a committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred house bill 1233
an act prohibiting higher education
institution receiving states fund from
requiring face mask and covert 19
vaccinations for attendance
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
presented rick ladd for the majority of
the committee
having the minority of the committee
having considered the same venable
degree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator david
luna from the minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion stage of motion
as to
uh table house bill 1233
table 1233
the motion is the table house bill 1233
that is a proper motion
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
house bill 1233 is laid on the table
okay members will stay in their seats
we have another
bill coming up right now that is just
going to be
parliamentary inquiries
the majority of the committee on
education to which was referred house
bill 1241 an act prohibiting a school
district from mandating a covenanting
vaccination for school attendance been
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass sent of glenn cordelli from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and be an enabled
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate
representative stephen woodcock from the
minority of the committee
this is going to be a division vote so
members take your seats the chair
recognizes representative woodcock for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill is attempting
to take a quick ride in the back of the
recent pandemic furore and is not sound
if i know that this bill is entirely
superfluous
as the department of health and human
services charges the responsibility of
determining which vaccines will be
required for missions to public school
and not this legislature
then i would press the red button and
then the waste of time on this frivolous
and unforeseeable bill and in the words
of another no more no more
[Music]
the house will be in order
the chair recognizes representative
saudi for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill is about
medical freedom and parental choice and
that my children are mine
and not the property of a school board's
school district or any other government
agency
and if i know that parents are the ones
to make medical decisions for their
children and themselves for that matter
and finally if i know that the right of
conscience the right to make choices is
a moral virtue and valued in a civil
society but i then press the green
button
and i would request the roll call vote
saudi requests a roll call vote is that
sufficiently seconded
we're in the voting mode my mistake
we're in the voting mode this is going
to be a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
that's right
represent true
if all members president opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
166 voting 848 voting a
committee reporters adopted
once again i'm asking
if you want to do a division or a roll
call let us know so we can keep moving
without having to have a delay of
getting people back in in their seats
majority committee on education to which
was referred house bill 1261 enact
prohibiting the use of native american
mascots public schools colleges and
universities have been considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate president michael moffatt
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senate of david luna from the
minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
tanner to speak against committee report
thank you mr speaker
hb 1261
requires that no public education
institution that is supported in whole
or in part
by general fund money
use a native american mascot imager name
many of us grew up with images in the
media of cowboys and indians as cartoons
movies tv shows and mascots at our
schools
we never thought or realized how those
often derogatory images chants symbols
or names created stereotypes and
misleading information that was not only
offensive to native americans
but play a role in perpetuating racial
inequity
and feelings of inadequacy among their
youth in particular
these images affect the self-esteem of
native youth
their self-confidence
and their sense of identity
native american youth experience the
highest rate of suicide among young
people and young people have one of the
highest rates of suicide
native american mascot stereotypes
negatively affect how native americans
view the world
and their place in society and in turn
how society as a whole view views them
what may be perceived by some that these
mascots honor the various qualities and
attributes of native americans
native americans don't agree
the national congress of american
indians which represents hundreds of
tribal governments
oppose these sports stereotypes
the congress further states that the
national and regional tribal
organizations
individual tribal governments
state governments agencies organizations
and companies all have taken official
positions or actions in support of
ending harmful mascots
carcarks and stereotypes which just
contribute to a discrimination and
disregard for the dignity of native
peoples
these groups have been joined by large
numbers of civil rights organizations
educational institutions
youth advocacy advocacy
that's easy for me to say
mental health
religious and other national
organizations which have also taken
formal positions against harmful mascots
the u s commission on civil rights
believes that the use of a native
american image and nicknames in schools
is insensitive and should be avoided
schools have a responsibility to educate
their students
they should not use their influence to
perpetuate misrepresentations of any
culture or people
the ncaa
adopted a policy in 2005 prohibiting
colleges and universities with hostile
or abusive mascots nicknames or imagery
from hosting any ncaa championship
competitions
they do have an exception in their
policy that allows
some universities to keep their native
american nicknames in imagery
if it is based on a particular tribe and
have permission from that tribe to do so
in the national congress of american
indians reports that because of ongoing
education and advocacy in total
two-thirds or over two thousand indian
reference references in sports has been
eliminated in the last 35 years
but the job is not over we know that
many schools still have those images and
also the mascots
it's not just emotional activists that
understand
that when native american people find
native american mascots insulting
demeaning and racist we should listen
when they tell us it is harming their
youth perpetuating cultural practices
that rob them of
racial and social equity
we should listen
words nicknames images and mascots have
power and meaning
to honor native american peoples
we need to prohibit and end the harmful
indian mascots and bring a new level of
understanding to our communities our
schools and our colleges
i urge you to vote against the itl so a
motion of otp can be made thank you
chair recognizes representative hall
thank you mr speaker
today i rise in support of hb 1261
a bill that would prohibit the use of
native american mascots in public
schools colleges and universities
in 2002
the new hampshire state board of
education unanimously approved a
resolution calling for a prohibition on
native american mascots and schools
they acknowledged that the use of native
mascots had quote a detrimental effect
on the achievement education
self-concept and self-esteem of american
indian students
and here we are 20 years later still
debating the issue
research has repeatedly shown the
negative psychological educational and
social effect that these icons inflict
on indigenous people especially younger
native americans
according to the national indian council
on aging native communities experience
higher rates of suicide compared to all
other racial and ethnic groups in the
united states
tribal leaders continue to speak out
against radical racially insensitive
nicknames and logos that alienate and
mock the native american population
we heard testimony from two tribal
leaders of the kawasaki band of the
penacook abenaki people headquartered in
alton the place of narrowing waters
on behalf of their people they shared
their resentment toward the continued
misappropriated and abusive use of
indigenous culture and people
they noted that images of violence such
as bloody tomahawk or a menacing war
painted face are blatantly offensive and
considered to be racist to the majority
of indigenous peoples
members of a youth group in durham
voiced strong support for this bill
they ask that school mascots reflect
their
mascots generation
are respected respectful compassionate
and exclu and inclusive
to them this bill represents the type of
future and legacy they want to be proud
of and be a part of
we as a nation are experiencing a push
for racial justice
sports teams across the country are
gradually retiring native american
mascots and imagery that are often
viewed as racist and degrading
dartmouth college made the switch from
the indians to the big green nearly 50
years ago in new hampshire public
schools we now have the cole brown bears
and the merrimack valley lions
previously known as the comanches and
the indians
mlb's cleveland indians have been
rebranded as the cleveland guardians
yes we are making progress but certainly
not enough
in 2019 maine became the first state to
ban native american mascots in schools
it is now time for us the new hampshire
legislature to follow in the footsteps
of our neighbor and make good on what
the new hampshire state board of
education envisioned two decades ago
a prohibition of native american mascots
in all new hampshire public schools
it's time to stop perpetuating racism by
continuing the use of offensive
depictions of native americans in our
public institutions we must respect all
human beings please vote again
this itl motion so the motion of otp can
be made thank you
we're down to the last speaker
senate tanner has requested a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
the chair recognizes representative
moffat
yes
the chair recognizes representative
moffat
thank you mr speaker i couldn't hear you
the atlanta braves
were once upon a time the boston braves
they played
on
near fenway park in a different stadium
now the atlanta braves made some world
series
baseball fans i'm sure watch the world
series with the braves now the braves
had a
mascara if you will his name was chief
nakahoma
chief nakahoma lived in a teepee outside
the
yellowfield fence and when a brave hit a
home run chief nakahoma would come out
of his teepee and he'd do a war dance
and at the same time brave fans some of
you seen this on television such as
jimmy carter ted turner jane fonda would
do a tomahawk chop tomahawk being like
an indian hatchet
now eventually indigenous native
american indians were successful in
raising awareness that this was cultural
appropriation that this was offensive
you'll notice
that jane fonda ted turner jimmy carter
no longer do the tomahawk chalk
chief nakahoma has retired he's gone
away and this happened without a law
this happened because people talked to
each other people raised awareness that
this was offensive
stepping away from disrespectful
cultural appropriation
is fine and good
and again
it doesn't have to require a law
laws such as proposed in hb 1261 which
claims that uses of indigenous native
american symbology creates
in quote
an unsafe learning environment
really
there were mascots and there were
nicknames and there were symbols they're
not all the same chief nakahoma was a
mascot he has gone away i'm glad he's
gone away
most of us are okay with his retirement
but most folks are also okay
with other symbols and nicknames
including most indigenous native
american indians who appreciate
who appreciate the associations and are
honored by these associations a sports
illustrated survey
a few years ago found that 80 percent 80
percent of native american indians hold
favored
and appreciated
being honored with the associations that
they had with sports teams
indeed a member of our education
committee who is both shawnee and
cherokee bled shared that most of the
indians as she knows from her native
ohio
are not happy they're they're
disappointed and saddened that the
cleveland indians
and other cleveland guardians
it's it's troubling to many that that
activists seem uninterested in in in
communicating and compromise you know it
doesn't need to be all or nothing we
don't need to issue and get rid of all
indian symbols nicknames mascots
his favorite colleges dean wermer once
famously said no more fun for anyone
this measure
is also
a clear violation of our first amendment
guarantee of freedom of expression i'll
say that again because it's important
this bill
to many of us is a clear violation of
our first american
our first amendment's guarantee of
freedom of expression
and further
this was and should remain a local
control issue
teams from my merrimack valley school
district used to be known as the indians
now they're the the blue prime
this came about
following local discussion local
dialogue local debate
if hb 1261 passed in the heavy hand of
the state
via this proposed statute would quash
such local discussions with all its
associated teaching moments
locally
if the good folks in colebrook want to
retain the mohawk as their symbol then
let them
discuss that locally if the good folks
at laconia
want to retain their sachem
let them debate that locally
if the good folks in belmont want to
retain the red raider then let them let
that local dialogue occur
the good folks at
hanover high school decided they no
longer wanted to be marauders
marauders aren't even indians but
that's i'm not from hanover
they chose to be bears
and that's a local decision
speaking of hanover
it's the home as most of you know of
dartmouth it used to be the dartmouth
indians why were they the dartmouth
indians because dartmouth was founded in
hanover in
as a school to educate indigenous native
american indians there's a historical
tie there a proud historical tie and
when dartmouth issued
the indian as their symbol from all over
the country
native american chiefs expressed their
dismay and their disappointment that
this historical connection to dartmouth
was
assumed as i put it
so
activists are even going after nicknames
like the warriors now warriors
is fairly generic um
our good friend from londonderry and
c333 is a warrior and he's an
italian-american not even a native
american warriors is not necessarily
indigenous and yet
people winter kind of wars or whatever
that
warriors could be greek whatever
so this is going far beyond
native american symbology
so we already have too many laws i say
many of us say let's not add another one
that would be an unconstitutional
infringement of first amendment
protections of freedom of speech freedom
of expression while also taking away
local control
and those teaching
moments
that we could use again chief and
oklahoma has gone away they didn't need
a lot and neither do we so please
when the time comes press that
dartmouth indian big green shiny button
to support the committee recommendation
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is
will the member yield to a question
sure it's up to the member
remember you may inquire mr speaker
thank you and i thank the distinguished
gentleman for taking my question
merrimack high school's mascot are the
tomahawks
should the bill be passed into law and
signed by the governor
what would happen to the tomahawk name
what would what would be the process in
the town for them to change the name
thank you
good question uh tomahawk as i mentioned
tomahawk chop it's an indian hatchet
uh i guess merrimack high school are the
tomahawks so if this bill passed then
the lancers the londonderry lancers
the native americans just use lancers
with the lancers have to go away the
tomahawks have to go away because i
didn't need a connection i don't know
but if this bill passed i can tell you
that there will be lawyers who will cite
this new statute
and london america londonderry other
towns are going to have to deal with
with lawsuits that i think could be
avoidable
thank you
the motion before us is
the majority report of inexpedient to
legislator in house bill 1261
this is a roll call vote
members take your seats
alright
house will be in order
the chair recognizes representative luna
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know the use
of native american mascots and monikers
and slurs
in high school
is offensive
and if i know
that's an uncontested fact because
members of the penacook abenaki
representing
represented the indigenous people
actually said that to the committee
they said it to the committee
and if i know this bill would prohibit
this practice at public schools and
colleges
then would i press the red button and
stop this offensive practice thank you
gee i recognize representative bone for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that this bill is
against the first amendment of the u.s
constitution by abridging freedom of
speech
and mr speaker if i know it is up to
your school district to determine what
name or mascot is appropriate for your
school
and mr speaker i know that there are
other ethnic names and mascots may also
cause some consternation
among people and others may like their
ethnicity used and mr speaker i know
that not everyone agrees on everything
we now press the green button to pass
this itl motion thank you
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of inexpedient to
legislator in house bill 1261. this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
170 voting yay 143 voting aid the
committee reporters adopted
majority committee on education to which
was referred
house bill 1283 an act relative to
liability as taxable income of education
freedom accounts having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate
representative glenn cordelli for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same of being able to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative david luno for the
minority of the committee
uh for what reason does a member rise
thank you mr speaker i rise to make a
motion stage of motion make a motion of
uh table for hb 1283
that is a proper motion the motion
before us
is to table house bill 1283.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and house bill 1283 is
laid on the table
the majority of the committee on
education to which was referred house
bill 1298 fn enact relative to
eligibility for the education tax credit
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative glenn
cordelli for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator stephen
woodcock for the minority of the
committee
the chair recognizes representative
woodcock
thank you mr speaker
i don't know about you
but i donate often to organizations
events
charities schools
i'm not sure how many goodies i bought
at the school bake sales i'm sure my
tailor knows based on the time she
changed my pants
but
every high school sport game has a 50 50
raffle
heck i even rode across the united
states on a motorcycle raising money for
disabled veterans
but in each case
each case from the outset the mission of
the organization and the requirements
they didn't change halfway through
needy families
are needy families
food is secure students are hungry
and they don't know where the next meal
is coming from and their food is secure
low income is low income and a disabled
vet is a disabled vet
but this bill plays games with that
concept of transparency
the sponsor the sponsor said and i quote
this legislation makes one simple change
in a program
it changes the income income eligibility
gap from three hundred percent to five
hundred percent of the federal poverty
level
one simple change
that means in simple language
a family of four in new hampshire with
an income of about seventy nine thousand
dollars would qualify for a tax credit
scholarship sounds reasonable
especially considering the current
minimum wage the cost of housing food
insurance
but when the number jumps to five
hundred percent
now we're talking about a family of four
with
132 thousand dollars income
that doesn't sound like a low income to
me
that's way above the median new
hampshire income of around 79 000 for a
family of
four last year
the scholarship organization
had a waiting list at 300 percent they
had a waiting list
more students waiting than the number of
students that they were able to provide
scholarships for
so
why if an organization
can't fund the number of low-income
eligible applications now
why would we want to enlarge the pool of
applicants
and further why would we want to expand
it to families that are making almost 50
000 more a year than those at 300
percent level
this organization was established to
provide scholarships to low income
families period
by the way during the testimony there
were not any statements from the
organization or cell phone
representative indicating that all
or most or half
the low income families would be
serviced first before the high rank of
families
this shouldn't be a bait and switch and
once again the poorest families of our
state are cast aside to make room for
those less needy
this program was set up to serve the
needy the low income
once that mission is filled and there
are no more waiting lists maybe maybe
that's the time to change or perhaps
even a larger scholarships but not now
when the organization the education
scholarship organization
can't even fund the number of
youngsters that are eligible why would
we change
we can't fund those folks so please
folks vote no now is not the time to
reduce aid to those that need us the
most thank you
representative luna has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded we're
down to the last speaker it is
sufficiently seconded this is going to
be a roll call vote members take your
seats we're down to the last speaker
chair recognizes representative cordelli
thank you mr speaker
the education tax credit program relies
on donations from businesses and
individuals in exchange for tax credit
there is no public money involved
and what is the program benefit
scholarships are awarded to students to
find the education option that best
meets their needs
and is the program successful you bet
there is a waiting list as was just
mentioned
a recent parent survey found that 94
percent of parents were satisfied with
their
scholarship program not one parent was
dissatisfied with their
child's new education option
let me repeat that no parent
dissatisfied
and this is the best form of
accountability
parent accountability
you see unlike other education options
that we are all familiar with
parents are free to leave and find
another education option if they are
dissatisfied
yes the program does have an eligibility
income of 300 percent of federal poverty
about one-third of families in new
hampshire qualify for that
but too often
government programs provide for
low-income families but ignore the
middle class
this bill will income will increase the
income limit to 500 percent of federal
poverty
and i want to be clear about the effect
of this increase
scholarships are awarded based on the
number and amount of donations
there will have to be a significant
increase in donations for any child to
get a scholarship based based on this
increase
by law forty percent of the scholarships
have to be awarded to students with a
family income of 185 percent of federal
poverty or less
last year that percentage was 68 percent
if the increase will not help anyone
right away
why do it
this legislation will send a message
it will send a message to families that
this house believes that every child
deserves the best possible education
and will meet their needs it will send a
business a message
that opportunity is needed for all new
hampshire children
this program is about providing
opportunity opportunities and if we can
send these messages and provide for
middle-income families in the future
then you need to press the green button
motion before us is the majority report
about to pass this is going to be a roll
call vote
members take your seats
the motion before us the majority report
of auto pass on house bill 1298 this is
a roll call vote the chair recognizes
representative ludl for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you very much mr speaker
if i know new hampshire's 160 000 public
school kids perform among the best in
the country and that's what parents want
and if i know the tax credit voucher
program was billed as a way for lower
income families to pay for private
school tuition using taxpayer dollars
and if i knew no this bill opens the
floodgates
so a family of four four earning more
than 132 thousand dollars a year
in the top 20 percent of statewide
income earners
can get in on this free money on the
backs
of our taxpayers would i then press the
red button to keep the program as it was
intended thank you
chair recognizes representative ladd for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know new hampshire's
tax credit scholarship program helps
hundreds of students access schools that
are right fit for them and if i know
this bill amends eligibility for a
scholarship to 500 percent of the
federal poverty le line and provides an
average scholarship of about twenty nine
hundred dollars per student which is
about seventeen percent of the average
expenditure per students at new
hampshire's public schools and if i also
know 40 percent of scholarship
recipients benefiting from this
education choice program come from
families with 185 percent or less the
federal poverty level would i then
continue to support the children's
scholarship fund by pressing the green
button thank you
motion before us is a majority report of
how to pass on house bill 1298 it's a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
159 voting yay 152 voting a
committee report is adopted
mr speaker
what purpose remember rise
thank you mr speaker having voted on the
prevailing side on bill
hb 1298 i would move reconsideration and
urge a no vote
the motion before us is reconsideration
on house bill 1298
and a division has been requested
members take their seats
the motion before us is a
reconsideration on 1298.
this is going to be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative luno
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know the
intention behind the tax credit uh
program scholarship program was billed
as a way for lower income families to
pay for private school tuition
and if i know that that this bill opens
the floodgates so that the top 20
percent of income earners would also be
able to get on this deal wouldn't i then
press the green button and um and allow
this body to reconsider this vote thank
you
the motion before us is the
reconsideration on house bill 1298
chair recognizes representative ladd for
parliament thank you very much mr
speaker if i know the education tax
credit as an education choice bill would
i then vote
red
the motion before us is the
reconsideration motion on house bill
1298 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
if all members president had an
opportunity to
if all america's president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
152 voting yay 162 voting a the motion
for reconsideration fails
chair recognizes the member from auburn
representative osborne for a third
reading motion thank you resolve that
the house now adjourned from the early
session that the business of the late
session be in order at the present time
that the reading of bills be by title
only in resolutions by captions only and
that all bills ordered the third reading
be read a third time by this resolution
and that all titles of bills be the same
as adopted and that they be passed at
the present time and when the house
adjourns today it be to meet wednesday
march 16th 2022 at 9 00 a.m
the house will be in order
is on the third reading motion are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
and the motion is adopted representative
has been moved that the house stand in
recess for the purpose of introduction
of bills and road billed amendments
enrolled bill reports receiving messages
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes the eyes have it and the motion
is adopted the house is in recess until
wednesday march 16 2022 at 9 00 am
please please please
please press your button for attendance
you